oh Elon Elon announced today that he's
working with a bunch of grievance
organizations to police hate speech and
harassment on Twitter congratulations
the people who hate you always hate you
and are lying about you are still lying
about you because even after this
meeting they're now ragging on him still
saying he's unleashing hate targeting
underprivileged communities so what a
good waste of time that was on top of
this Elon announced they're working with
an organization that admittedly produced
Bots to interfere in an election
hurting Republicans of course a lot of
people pointed out it was going to go
like this because elon's not firing one
of the top people who was involved in
censorship calling Trump supporters
Nazis this guy Joel Roth but here we go
now elon's coming out and saying I'm
getting attacked by the left and the
right that means I'm doing something
good it's like bro you're getting
attacked by everybody like moderates are
mad it's not just conservatives it's
because independent voters moderate
voters whatever you want to call them if
they're voters if that even matters in
the culture War that's that's what
matters more Independence and
Republicans are basically like dude we
have been compromising endlessly
and the left keeps making demands and
Twitter kept giving in to their demands
and now that elon's in he's like I'm
gonna keep giving in to the whiny
demands okay you know what dude I'm not
paying for your garbage I canceled
Twitter blue I'm not paying for it if
you're not going to reinstate people
there was one guy who got reinstated
maybe we'll see more I still think it's
a net positive but dude if you're going
to start working with grievance
organizations an active election
manipulators does not like look like a
good sign so the moment you start fixing
it maybe then I'll consider paying but
we'll talk about that I don't want to
rant too much because we've also got
oh man the White House put out this
boastful tweet about how they were uh
the bite administration's leadership was
resulting in a social security increase
and then it got fact checked by the
community actually that was Nixon and it
was automatic and it was due to the
insane inflation rate so they deleted
the Tweet they accidentally celebrated
the fact that there's extremely high
inflation under Joe Biden Bravo major
major win there so we'll talk about that
plus the new Real Clear Politics
projection it has Republicans winning 54
Senate seats New Hampshire has now
flipped red according to this projection
so we'll see we don't know for sure and
Russia is saying the five nuclear powers
are on the verge of war and that's going
to get really really bad I certainly
hope not so before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member to
support our work directly as a member
you're keeping our journalists employed
and we really do appreciate it you'll
also get access to our exclusive
uncensored members only shows those will
go up Monday through Thursday at 11 PM
we'll have one of those for you tonight
you don't want to miss so don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share this show with your
friends and also big announcement
go to losing my mind.net I'm not sure if
it's working on mobile yet but uh this
is the pre-save for the new song
genocide that we're releasing on Friday
if you take a look at that graphic you
might get a general idea of what the
song's about
and I'll just leave it at that because
this is YouTube but again losing my
mind.net Spotify Apple Amazon Beezer I
don't know Deezer is but you can
pre-save it so that come Friday morning
you'll be able to listen to the song we
have a video that's going live Friday
first thing and I'm sure it's gonna
piss a lot of people off but it's
YouTube friendly it's just you know
directly mocking the people who are
manipulating and trying to lie cheat and
steal and and you know manufacturing a
narrative as it were so I'm really
excited for this again losing my
mind.net which honestly I could not
believe was actually available and I got
it for 10 for 15 bucks that's amazing so
uh super cool joining us today to talk
about this and so much more is Lord
miles
hey guys who are you oh uh my name is
Lord miles and I've helped the most
dangerous places in the world so I've
traveled to Afghanistan during the fall
of Kabul front lines of Ukraine and
kharkiv London in some places very
dangerous places really so just all
around the world I'll go anywhere right
on you actually have fake immigrant IDs
that you were talking about oh yeah so
that's crazy so you found this at the
border yes so I went to the Mexican
border at Eagle Pass recently in Texas
and the Situation's really bad down
there Tim I mean when I was on the the
Mexican side there's hundreds of these
IDs just listed around left behind by
migrants because if they can't uh see
where they're from they'll just send
them back to Mexico and then they can
try again to come into this country
illegally uh bypassing the real people
that are doing it properly so they have
fake IDs to trick their way and it's not
just them walking through it's them
manufacturing fake documents even
manufacturing or bribing the police are
very people that are governments are
funding to actually protect our borders
as well so it's a terrible situation too
right on we'll talk about all that too
we got Luke gradkowski if we are change
hanging out hey guys interest rates are
up so I decided to wear my banker
t-shirts to help people understand what
a banker is with with the true
definition uh saying that a banker is
quote a ruthless scumbag who will eat
your lunch and then charge you for it
this is a great way to meet like-minded
individuals I met a couple Bankers
wearing this shirt great conversations
and when you get this shirt this is the
main way that you support me and my
efforts here you could get the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com thank you
again so much for having me what I love
about Banks is that when you're poor
they charge you and when you're rich
they give you money that's amazing how
that works isn't it it's crazy because
they're using your money to invest it's
like a big pyramid scheme and if you're
if you're invested in the pyramid they
want to reward you for getting into it
good to see you miles oh thank you uh
you were in Afghanistan too yeah it was
lovely nice little Lads holiday I guess
or Ukraine as well yeah yeah better
London sometimes I want to go deep into
all this and hear about the last year or
so of what you've been up to thank you
of course um also I second Tim's
statement about getting pre-ordering
genocide the song it's incredible I
worked on it um it was really fun to
make he's got the best part in the music
video to be honest yeah it's hilarious
it's hilarious the video is crazy it's
so loud we just we made it uh anyway I
won't spoil anything get ready for that
song coming out Friday losing my
mind.net I like it yeah and of course
I'm searching.com pleasure to meet you
miles looking forward to the show thank
you man all right so our first story
ladies and gentlemen Elon Musk says he
met with latino civil rights leader but
the organization says she's a rogue
ex-employee
okay uh sure in a separate statement the
leaders of the NAACP the National Urban
League and the National Action Network
blasted musk for unleashing the worst of
human nature
you see Elon look man we were fans
because you said you like The Babylon
bee because you pushed back on the
establishment and then the moment you
get into Twitter not even a week later
you go crawling to these organizations
to try and and he tweets this out to to
figure let them know how we're going to
be handling hate and harassment and what
do they do they attack you for it
Twitter owner Elon Musk I love I love
that that phrase said early Wednesday
that he spoke with the leaders of
various civil rights groups about his
efforts to combat hate and harassment
except one organization said he met with
a rogue employee who was fired last
month and another attendee blasted the
Mogul for unleashing the worst of human
nature
actually said that he unwittingly freed
people to unleash the worst of human
nature with communities of color and
religious minorities bearing the
greatest burden so uh Bravo Elon he
tweeted talk to Civil Society leaders
about how Twitter will continue to
combat hate and harassment and enforce
its election Integrity policies ah yes
what's that all about you see I'm
actually blocked from seeing the tweet
from this diresta woman Joel Roth says
we're staying Vigilant against attempts
to manipulate conversations about the
2022 midterms read on for independent
analysis of our team's work and he
linked to a woman who was an executive I
believe she's an executive or some high
ranking position with new knowledge an
organization that was outed for creating
bots for for manufacturing or doing
something they sent them towards Roy
Moore that so that the media would think
he was being propped up by Russians
that's what this organization was doing
and elon's Consulting them on an
election Integrity okay I'll tell you
what I think the advertisers went to
Elon right away and said we're pulling
out he said wait wait wait like we're
going to keep policing hey trust me
trust me don't leave we need your money
and they said we don't care then he said
okay will charge 20 bucks then the left
said nope we're out we're not paying 20
bucks it goes okay fine eight dollars
eight dollars and you know we said we
were like okay like if if on under the
assumption that Elon was gonna fix the
platform and do right by Free Speech an
actual American values I'll spend more
than eight dollars then Elon has the
nerve to come out and be like actually
we're gonna combat hate with the very
same grievance organizations that will
never be satisfied and why if they are
satisfied they cease to exist none of
these people are going to come out and
be like my job here is done fire me
because there's no more hate anymore
there will always be hate if it's not a
racial slur it's the word groomer so
Elon Musk pandering these people is a
waste of our time I'll tell you this I
am not going to spend any money Elon he
comes out and he's like it's going to be
eight dollars keep complaining all right
bro look
I think there's a net positive here with
you buying the platform I'm not going to
spend a penny I canceled Twitter blue is
bad enough I had in the first place I'm
actually the moment I saw he did this I
was like okay I'm giving them less money
now the moment he did this so I'll tell
you if he releases the information on
the DHS and how Twitter was colluding
with the government I'll I'll pay eight
bucks but he's also got to free the
political prisoners and fire the people
who are involved in the hunter Biden
laptop Scandal yeah this was
disappointing because he kind of tweeted
it like he was bragging about it and you
know you mentioned some of the
organizations but some of them you
didn't mention uh were individuals the
the president of the vice president of
the ADL the NAACP the George Bush
Foundation what Satan wasn't available
you is like truly like are you kidding
me and and then you're bragging about
how you're going to be continuing the
policies when it comes to uh your hate
and election interference and and again
this clearly shows a signal that this is
going in the Raw long Direction and I'm
happy at this time that I have my own
website that I have my own platform
you're probably happy Tim that you have
your own platform as well because at the
end of the day this is very
disappointing news and shows us that
we're going down a very bad Road I'm a
huge advocate of knowing thine enemy and
working with your foe I think Abraham
Lincoln talked about it the best way to
win over an enemy to destroy an enemy is
to make them your friend your ally not
not only do you no longer have an enemy
but you have an extra Ally in case
another enemy appears so I'm into this
idea of like getting to know that you're
the people that are against you but at
the same time Trump putting Bolton in
his cabinet early on bad move Obama
getting the Goldman Sachs team on all
these like bankers and into his cap or
in his inner circle right away they they
start to manipulate you when you
surround yourself with people you become
those people like you are a result of
your closest six friends or something so
at some point you got to just cut you
gotta cut and run and make a move I
think that Elon came into this with no
real plan and now he's trying to build
the plan quickly that's why he wanted to
back out but take a look at this this is
from the Federalist Elon Musk Taps Jesse
smilet hoaxer for Twitter censorship
advice
ah brilliant brilliant look man I like
Elon he does a lot of really cool stuff
but he has an opportunity to talk to
people and he's choosing to talk to the
people who made the problems one of
these guys says what more evidence does
Chicago Police need to call what
happened to Jesse Smith what it is I
hate crime this guy started calling this
stuff out after we already knew it was a
hoax
this and so this is who Elon Musk is
going to why you know what man Elon I
got to tell you he's very naive
I will say it again I met up in Texas
with a bunch of these big Tech Guys
a lot of them were apparently like
worked with or friends with Elon and it
was amazing listening to them speak
because they do not understand culture
they think it's a technology problem the
reason Elon Musk is maybe these people
is because he's probably like everyone
has got a good point to be made
technology will solve the problem and
you're like dude
Independents and conservatives already
have stated we've compromised we don't
like The Fringe cult weirdos but they're
allowed to be on the platform and say
what they want to say the French cult
weirdos went to you and said if you
don't ban all of the people we don't
like we're leaving and in response what
Jack Dorsey and vagina did was okay okay
wait it's this simple the right isn't
leaving even when we ban them and the
left is threatening to leave unless we
ban more right Wingers hey let's ban
more right Wingers let's ban more
Independents and Libertarians and
liberals and now Elon seems to be doing
the exact same thing now it's early
we'll see what happens maybe this is a
cold splash of water in the face that'll
wake Elon up the reason why I'm
frustrated about it and calling it out
right now is because if we don't Elon
will walk down that path and Twitter
will become worse than it was before I
think there's there's a the ideal is a
build a neutral platform where everyone
can co-exist together the reality is
that can't function you need small lots
and lots of small platforms that
interact with each other and so
you need to censor and moderate Twitter
Elon that is your job now you own the
network you control the network you are
the one that needs to censor the network
whether you're censoring it as American
law if it violates American law then
it's off the platform child porn get it
off the platform that's your light
censorship or if you're going heavy it's
up to you but give the code out to
everyone so that they can make versions
of the site so that they can monitor it
and do it the way they want if they want
to do you know if you say the word the
and you get banned off their platform
fine but we need lots and lots and lots
of terms of service right now we can't
rely on you and your network to do it
and we never should we never should have
to yeah so just to recap so people
understand what's going on here
Twitter's head of safety specifically
cited Renee de Rista she's she's a part
of the new knowledge organization that
Twitter that that Tim just discussed
with their activities with what they
were doing before she's also on video
discussing censorship with Bill Gates
and then under that Elon Musk was like
Hey we're also working with George W
bush in the ADL and we have a diverse
group of voices here no you don't you
you have a group of individuals who hate
Free Speech you have a group of
individuals who have been trying to
punish people for their political speech
and that's essentially what a lot of
these organizations represented I didn't
know all of them but some of the
organizations that are involved here
that are going to be continuing the
policies as Elon Musk said is worrying
on top of what Elon Musk said after that
saying specifically it's going to take a
couple weeks to make sure that people
are unbanned from this platform a couple
weeks what are we waiting for yeah no
seriously I mean as a sign look
you want me to come and spend money
where's the good faith this is the way I
described it earlier today in my morning
show
when I go to McDonald's I can actually
see the burgers under the heat lamps I
know they're they're sitting right there
you tell me you make burgers I can see
the burgers okay I'm gonna give you
eight bucks hand me one of those Burgers
Elon Musk comes in Pay eight bucks and
we're gonna do these things and I'm like
okay well show me that you actually do
that and I'll consider giving you money
for the time being it looks like this is
probably why he didn't want to buy the
platform it's not just about
whether or not he could monetize it it's
that I'm willing to bet he knew I wonder
that no matter what he does the left
will refuse to work with him he's a
billionaire Communists don't want to pay
for things and they're not going to
they're not going to pay a billionaire
so maybe he was like okay if I buy this
platform there's a lot of Communists in
this company they're going to quit no
matter what I do advertisers are going
to pull out no matter what I do I better
not buy it then he was forced to buy it
now he's desperately pleading with him
please please I'll do whatever you say
they said they were there's already ad
agencies boycotting Twitter so strip it
down to the Bare Bones make it a
protocol or do something let the company
just fizzle who cares man
well probably that Saudi Prince cares I
think he's still got a few billion in
the in the deal right now I wonder if
Elon bid off more than he can shoot with
this one I wonder if the people that
helped him because he didn't front the
44 billion I know there's other people
involved Saudi Prince is one of them um
if they have decision-making power I
don't think so I think elon's got Sole
decision-making power but I wonder if
they're like are you going to make this
profitable dude because you said you
were going to make this profitable now
the advertisers are leaving it's go time
where's the what's the income model he's
like 20 bucks a month I mean the way he
went from 20 bucks a month to eight
bucks a month in like a day kind of
indicates that he has no he had no plan
and he's just like almost like having
fun at this point so honestly I don't
think the whole like wait two weeks to
unban people is that big of a deal you
know we waited this long it's been a
year and a half I think that two weeks
is reasonable for a new owner to make a
move on his Network I disagree if if
Elon Musk is not going to come in with a
sledgehammer he's never going to come
with a sledgehammer he's going to keep
trying to say
okay okay leftist okay okay I'm trying
I'm trying please I know you're
screaming at me because you know the
reality is
the I don't like saying the right
because post-liberals dispected liberals
they're not right wing I guess they are
now whatever
there's never any uproar like Twitter
never feared that Dave Rubin or Carl
Carl Benjamin would march with a bunch
of liberalists and classic liberals
Twitter HQ with with pitchforks they've
consistently feared it will be the left
no one cares when a bunch of
conservative rarely I should say but
it's happened but the right typically
doesn't start boycotts and go after big
corporations when they do it works but
the left does it all the time
so right now Twitter be it under Elon
Musk or Virginia they know that they can
do whatever they want and the right has
a higher tolerance for BS and the left
has zero tolerance so if you want to
create a bounce platform you've got to
give the left whatever they want because
the right the adults Will Roll their
eyes and be upset about it the left or
the temper tantrum claim you're trying
to murder them and then quit the
platform in Anger which is what's
happening right now but I'll make it
does get worse we have this in this
tweak thread Mike cernovich
to give you the context for those just
tuning in yoel Roth a guy who claimed
Trump was a Nazi head of safety says we
are staying Vigilant against attempts to
manipulate conversations about the 2022
midterms read on for independent
analysis of our team's work
unfortunately we can't because I'm
blocked by a person I don't know that's
ideological neutrality I guess a Elon
Elon Musk responded saying he's working
with these grievance organizations but
this woman whose Twitter account I can't
see because I am blocked is Renee
diresta Mike cernovich points out Renee
diresta is the director of research at
cyber security company new knowledge and
head of policy at the non-profit data
for democracy new knowledge got caught
buying Russian Bots to follow Roy Moore
on Twitter during the 2018 midterms it's
an odd source to rely on for an
independent analysis of the 2020 2022
midterms
so uh where's the rest of Mike's tweets
why are they breaking it up like that's
kind of weird
they did that anyway Mike cernovich goes
on to point out for some reason
Twitter's not loading it that's
fascinating I guess
there we go when Russian Bots began
following Roy Moore in 2017 it was
treated as a huge as a huge National
story Moore was mocked for blaming
Democrats yes Democrats bought the Bots
and hoaxed the Willing press now someone
who works for new knowledge the same
firm is on 2022 integrity that's
actually actually sounds
basically as bad as the DHS conspiring
with Twitter to manipulate elections
Elon Musk is now actively working with
an organization that manipulated the
elections to help Democrats okay
so I mean I'm sorry guys if it's if it's
a bit you know it's black pilling or
whatever you want to say it's
pessimistic
it's what's happening I'm what do you
think Miles about this will this impact
your use of of Twitter how do you think
Elon what do you how do you think Elon
is doing here oh yeah I've got no backup
I'm completely screwed on social media
if it goes south but truthfully I never
really had faith on Elon Musk because
he's in bed with these people these
corporations and really powerful people
no matter what like a coach you'll be
pressured into it otherwise you'll be
kicked out of the circle and everything
collapses behind you like a sand castle
When the tide comes in these these
people are not living in reality are
they they don't understand how things
work how Society works and also how a
platform like this works and no matter
what like Tim said these people are
children they're gonna throw a fit until
everything collapses apart now I just
really hope Elon Musk gets to a point
where he gets so upset he just doubles
down and just says hey guys it's gonna
be a right-wing Utopia right-wing
quotations and then those people will
realize that they're screaming and whiny
will not do anything and then from there
something is actually built something
better for a future where we can invest
knowing where our Free Speech will be
upheld but I don't see it happening I'm
pessimistic but I guess we just can't
let go and roll out and see what the
time says it's beyond just the walk left
screaming now I mean true this is
election interference this is Elon Musk
colluding with an organization that
interfered in the 2018 midterms to help
Democrats win as they're bragging how
they're going to have control of this
upcoming midterm election they're
literally saying hey the same people
that did this we're the same guys who
are going to be watching what's going to
be happening in the upcoming midterm and
they're bragging about it that that's
like that's mud in your face that that's
absolute absolutely disrespectful and as
you mentioned miles again yeah he has a
lot of government contracts he does a
lot of business with China and with that
comes a lot of pressure because when
you're working with the government
that's giving you a lot of money the
government could say we're going to give
you a little bit less you know those
satellites you know those spaceships you
know maybe we don't want to finance you
maybe we don't want to do this if you
all do this or do this or do this for us
uh musk also you know promoted World
Government before he's a transhumanist
he supported the vaccines carbon tax a
universal basic income so a lot of the
policies that he puts forward should be
obviously questioned since I would say
they go along with an agenda that is
very questionable as well yeah it lines
up a little bit with the world economic
Forum yeah a little bit too much I like
the guy likes memes I like that he
triggered a lot of these people all
those are not positives and there is
there was a republican I think in
Arizona who got suspended Elon said
looking into it and the guy got
reinstated so we don't know for a fact
Elon did that there are net positives
here I don't want to come out and just
be like the end is nigh and elon's
terrible I think there's bad things he's
doing and we need to tell him we will
not tolerate it so he's coming out and
saying oh everybody's mad at me he's
like the left and the right are both mad
at me and it's like dude
who do you think is going to pay the
money the left hates you they've always
hated you and they're quitting the
platform and lying about you they're
coming out and saying since Elon took
over hates gotten substantially worse
despite the fact that elon's team has
said no we've actually been policing
these are bot accounts and we're getting
rid of them
doesn't matter Democrats are coming out
and saying that he's charging eight
dollars for free speech maybe Elon must
learn that these people are whiny babies
that will never be satisfied unless you
give them everything and if you're not
willing to give them everything then you
need to tell them to go bye-bye there's
there's the room you can go hang out and
play by yourself go to your other social
media network but they're not going to
be here they're never going to be
satisfied oh exactly and the thing is
too these these big leftist accounts
most of them are Bots anyway but you
have no real following in the real
worlds on paper maybe yes but Elon has
to Remember at the end of the day the
right-wing people are the ones that
actually are supporting him like you
said and if we get behind him and rally
him to actually do the right thing
things will come together
at the end of the Devo
um
I think things are screwed I think Elon
Musk is going to crumble he's gonna give
in what do you guys think what about 750
Elon okay can we do 750 I'm just I'm
just joking
look I'd pay 20 bucks yeah he's offering
up for Twitter a suite of of Premium
tools and it does help get rid of bots
all that I'm totally down for that I do
think he should be paying top creators
which he also announced is in the is in
the pipeline but I'm not going to give
any money until he frees the political
prisoners I'm not going to spend money
on a platform that sucks and Twitter
sucked for a long time I barely care
about it I post garbage nonsense memes
like advocating for war and neutering
children come on or is taking the advice
and policies from the people that made
it suck and are going to make it suck
that much more which he's bragging about
today which again it's still early a lot
of people are arguing like Hey we're
still not even a week in here let's give
him time let's see what happens here but
I think during this time I think we're
at a crucial point where we need to hold
his feet to the fire we need to
criticize him whenever he Goofs up I
think this was a major goof up I think
this also highlights a major problem
moving forward that could be very
significant for the prospects of free
speech and I'm willing to pay twenty
dollars I'm willing to pay a hundred
dollars if we have free speech these
organizations that he's working with
don't support free space and that's a
big problem it's funny Elon did say he
bought Twitter to help save Humanity
right yep what if what if his plan is to
destroy it because you know Twitter is
just bad oh he's got the spaceships too
he's playing to leave it and start his
own Humanity I guess you never know you
mean destroy Twitter not destroy Earth
yeah yeah well it's the same thing left
his eyes you know oh he buys Twitter and
then disassembles it and gives the parts
out to the the masses it's brilliant
that's exactly what he should do that'd
be amazing honestly if just like ah I
would I would love to see it you know
too many people tie their net worth
their their personal self-worth to their
Twitter accounts their verification
badges their following and all that
stuff and I'm just like
we need to take a figurative bucket full
of ice water and splash it in somebody's
face
there are too many people that look at
this and they're like it's all I have I
would I would I would laugh if I woke up
and Twitter was just gone and when you
go to twitter.com it's a picture of Elon
Musk giving a thumbs up saying Twitter
was bad for you from the get from the
get-go so suck it I'd be like ah yeah or
the Doge the dog Doge dog oh I got my uh
my Twitter shares I got cashed out um
the money appeared in my account so
you're indulge now I just put it all in
Dosh it's not a bad idea I've got about
6 500 doge coins sitting there in the
wings because I think doge is
essentially going to be Twitter stock
you know I'm I'm optimistic about this
because Elon essentially purchased
Twitter off of BlackRock he bought it
away from the global cartels the
international you know Mega corpse and
now he's taking it private or it's about
to become private I don't know if it's
technically off the public market now is
it already that's probably done now it's
private yeah so we talked about the
negative let's talk about some of the
positives here because I I got we got to
be honest here there are some things to
be optimistic about like Ian mentioned
here there there still is a prospect
there is still a possibility that a lot
of people could be brought back and
let's talk about some of the positives
here Viva Freight has been brought back
he didn't have to admit he was wrong to
get his account back he got his account
back a republican running in Arizona I
think got his account back without
having to apologize he's responding to
individuals that were hurt by the
platform before wrongly and saying don't
worry I'll fix this just give me some
time if you're optimistic if you want to
believe in him and have faith in him
sure believe in him uh there's also uh
the interaction he had with AOC today
which was absolutely hilarious and the
White House fact checked which is
absolute gold and no no I'm not giving
him credit for the White House fact
check because that already was happening
before him the the community I knew what
was happening to Donald Trump no but it
was it was happening across the board
well before Elon Musk took over it's
just we're in election season and
they've made some mistakes I haven't
noticed it before this this AOC thing is
funny she said LMAO at a billionaire
earnestly trying to sell people on the
idea that free speech is actually eight
dollars an eight dollars a month
subscription plan you see uh you know
Elon responded your feedback is
appreciated now pay eight dollars Elon
she's lying when did anyone say that
free speech is eight bucks no free
speech is free you can get a free
account on Twitter if you want premium
services that costs money but she's
lying yep I I don't get it does Elon not
get that he these people are are liars
free speeches and free free speech
requires taxes to pay for a military to
guard your borders so that you can say
things without getting shots
free speech exists and it is an inherent
right given by God because we have guns
to defend no that's not true well duh if
we didn't have guns to defend it we'd
get conquered by the CCP and would no
longer have free speech uh excuse me
if you're standing in China can you yell
out F the CCP I don't think so well you
can't your mouth this doesn't move
you're like you can but I don't know if
you'll get the last word like in Doctor
Strange when the you know black what
whatever the fork guy whatever his name
is what's that guy you know talking
about he's got the fork or whatever and
then he they're like he could kill you
with one whisper and then she's like
what mouth and he's like yeah that's
what happens when you go to China bro
you can speak it happens what you're
saying is that some people may try and
stop you well I'm saying you don't need
a government for that you like if you're
in the middle of the woods you can say
whatever no I'm talking about legal free
speech like American legal Free Speech
First Amendment stuff is protected by
guns no that's funded by money okay
that's not what Elon Musk is arguing
here Elon Musk is saying specifically
hey AOC you want to use the platform
it's free you don't have to pay eight
dollars for a verified badge he also
went on a tweet storm he tweeted uh some
of her merchandise that's 58 dollars for
a sweater uh he then also posted a bunch
of memes one of them being an NPC
laughing and being really happy smiling
about an eight bucks uh Starbucks latte
and then crying about eight bucks per
month
on Twitter so Props to him being in the
meme game and going against these people
and then willing to stand up for what he
believes in he's also talking about
setting up a video paywall which some uh
news organizations are talking about
could rival adult websites now if that
happens that again is questionable and
that negative for societies this is this
is what a lot of the mainstream media
Publications said that if he offers a
paywall for video he's going to be in
direct competition with the adult
websites who do something very similar
uh that would be again a net negative
sense there is a lot of adult content
already on Twitter I think it's 13 or 18
of Twitter is adult content
um and that is a net negative and is
somehow allowed which is still weird
which they might arbitrarily use against
him in the future because that's another
weak point of Twitter that somehow is
able to do this and other platforms
aren't on the major app stores that's a
good point uh mines was actually removed
from the Google app store because porn
was showing up on the site it was like
Hey Twitter has porn what is it one
nipple yeah it was it was something a
name it wasn't a lot and we were
attempting to moderate it but because
there was so much and there were human
moderators and like there were seven of
us or something we couldn't keep up it's
a rigged game man a few things get so
supported someone did Super Chat uh I
believe this is let me see who had the
super chair we don't really save him but
somebody good point Bren Bren Ben is
that what it says according to Jeremy
the quartering Elon has to play ball
because there's the Google Play Store
and server factors to keep in mind also
yoel Roth is only there still because he
knows where the bodies are it's fair
point you know so we'll see but Elon
doesn't need to be tweeting this stuff
out to Virtue signal
what's the like what is is Twitter going
to get banned from the Play Store why
would that happen like just oh you never
know correctly I mean maybe because of
collusion I mean it's happened a few
times
um there's an app called iFunny it was
free speech anyone could say anything it
was actually quite well moderated to
some degree you know nothing dodgy on
there but it got taken off 20 or
something times when something blows up
and leaks outside this app so I think at
some point he may double down just take
it out of the app store or the Play
Store parlor got banned because Donald
Trump was threatening to be on that
platform so we saw collusion if you
think there's collusion with big Tech
social media there's obviously collusion
with all the big uh app stores obviously
they're also going to be targeting
people politically just like they do on
big Tech social media and this is just
one Avenue and there could be a
possibility here that we have to
entertain of the DHS coming down and be
like we'll take you off the app store
we'll make sure you guys get hit for all
the adult website stuff you have on your
on your thing we'll make sure you guys
get punished uh unless of course you
allow George W bush and it's found
Foundation along with the ADL to decide
how we're going to be playing by the
rules here so that could be happening
right now and that again is another
possibility that is worth considering on
the other side about true social is
allowed on the app store right and
everyone hates Trump on the left right
they kicked him off Twitter but he's on
the App Store so that is hope for
Twitter in the end of the day yeah I
think that Google the transhumanists and
the technologists the technocrats don't
really have
they don't play the Left Right Paradigm
they're looking for like the most value
and efficiency out of the system
yeah unfortunately but the DHS like you
said has influence with them and but
that's why you know you know you free
the software code we'll build a
decentralized app store we can make F
Droid go go mainstream it's a little
wild west like you can download an app
that has a virus in it you gotta be
careful in F Droid but it's better than
relying on Google and Apple for our soul
I store Monopoly like we gotta we gotta
break up the the App Store Monopoly
agreed I want to talk about some
domestic politics but I want to talk
about this first so we can talk about
some International stuff from The Daily
Mail
the world's five nuclear superpowers are
on the brink of a direct armed conflict
which will have catastrophic
consequences the Kremlin said on
Wednesday that avoiding nuclear Clash
was its first priority Western capitals
have said Moscow is behind a ramping
above nuclear rhetoric Russia said that
it stood by a joint declaration for
avoiding a nuclear war I respect it
Vladimir Putin has appeared on several
occasions to threaten a nuclear strike
there's even some reporting that Putin
tried to launch a nuke but was sabotaged
by who we don't know aliens perhaps
perhaps not but uh that's at least one
report said so I'm wondering uh Lord
miles you're actually on the ground in
Ukraine oh yes you've witnessed a lot of
the stuff I'm curious if you think we're
facing an escalation that could bring us
to a nuclear conflict or will it just
remain Regional what do you think well I
think it'll be good business for me but
if I have to think about what would
happen I think it would be a very small
tactical nuke that might go off but at
the same time if you establish that
nuclear war you could wall can be done
tactically it will open up the
floodgates Pandora's Box and nukes will
start flying I feel like if the U.S sent
a new retaliation you'll probably hit
Twitter HQ before it hits Russia but I I
do think it would happen Putin is
desperate right now he wants this land
he's fantasized about it since the
Soviet Union fell apart and he's
desperate because he realizes the whole
country would turn against him and with
that much pressure on him right now
people don't think straight what if
there's a false flag what if there's a
strike on Russian soil he he could
probably then rally popular support in
Russia to do whatever he wants yeah I
would never have passed him because the
US government would do this too he might
set off uh it might do a false flag
himself uh cause a nuclear bomb to go
off in some remote area of Siberia or
whatever say it was some terrorists
going on that have been sent from
Ukraine and then just everyone rallies
behind him and some other countries send
extra troops and I don't think Siberia I
think Moscow you think I mean yeah
absolutely yeah the Russians are knowing
known for throwing away their men like
this right exactly soldiers yeah the the
zap bran again of of international
conflict the Russians it was the Soviets
pretty much the same thing I mean no
Russia is its own Beast sure sure the
Russian people are ancient
well and also there's a possibility that
the opposite of this could happen there
could be a false flag by Ukraine or by
Western Powers inside of Ukraine and
they could blame Russia for it to then
also use that again there's a lot of
potential for false Flags it it it's not
just the United States or Russia or
Ukraine that has the potential of
launching them it's also independent
third parties uh corporations the
military-industrial complex that has a
lot to gain and win here but this is an
absolutely crazy disastrous situation
the West is not trying to give any kind
of easy way out for Vladimir Putin
Vladimir Putin has put himself in an
extremely difficult situation there's a
lot of people being negatively affected
by this inside of Ukraine right now
their energy infrastructure has been
targeted they're facing a dark winter to
the point where they're telling their
refugees not to come back to the country
because they won't know if they're going
to have enough energy to heat the
country so this is a major problem this
is a humanitarian crisis this is
something that we need to deal with that
we need to de-escalate and come to a
table where we could negotiate a peace
deal but the exact opposite of that is
happening and they're calling for more
escalations more war more military
contracts which I think is absolutely
stupid I wanna oh are you gonna say
Mouse oh yeah well thank you we've got
to realize why the war actually begun
and it's because Russia fears that NATO
is moving closer and the corridor the
actual uh length of Europe is opening up
for them so they can't defend their
border soon uh easier because it's so
wide if they move further down you know
it's narrower and they can easily defend
that area especially with the
geographical boundaries so if they did
drop tactical nukes in a straight line
down they could claim part of Ukraine
but also means NATO can't move in even
further and no Army is going to send
their people through a nuclear Wasteland
right they just straight up die from
nuclear radiation poisoning and so on so
it could be the only way he secures
borders and the security of Russia in
general against NATO I mean a
radioactive wall yeah basically I mean
that's what um I think it was Douglas
Arthur fought about with China to
protect
um against uh North Korean aggression
you're right because China was supplying
North Korea during the Korean War he
proposed West dropping line of nukes and
they said no that's crazy but to be
there could it could work
it could be scary that it could work to
stop humans from walking maybe but I I
don't know it would be it would just be
insanity and you got the Russians
working with the French on building a
fusion reactor right now that's so weird
they said that they want to avoid at all
costs the the nuclear war I think the
actual what's the quote uh Russia is
strictly and consistently Guided by the
tenant that a nuclear war cannot be won
and must never be fought this is the
Russian foreign Ministry uh according to
NBC News I mean it could be one
it just means that the aftermath is you
live in a bunker for a little while
right and that's not a winning and then
afterwards a few hundred people try to
rebuild Society it's like how even the
poor in modern society are richer than
the richest kings from 500 years ago
we're all winning yeah it's it's
important to note here that a lot of
people escalating this conflict have
nuclear bunkers and they won't have to
deal with the larger consequences of the
larger problems of them escalating this
conflict sorry Ian I wanted to clarify
this statement about the Soviet Union
and Russia and how they're different
it's kind of like if the Nazis had won
World War II and created a new country
called or New Empire called the Third
Reich and Germany was part of the Third
Reich and then so the Soviet Union was
like the Third Reich it was this weird
totalitarian regime that took over
Russia and all these foreign other
countries so now we finally got rid of
like the Soviet Nazi party and now we're
back to like what Germany would be if we
had dispelled the not the Third Reich
later it would still have like remnants
of it but it's Germany is not the third
right but but Ian the Soviet Union was
largely Russia
with satellite States yeah they used
Russia that the Bolsheviks used Russia
they definitely took it but it wasn't
like like are Germans still German after
World War II yeah and when the fall of
the Soviet Union happened Russia was the
centerpiece and that is literally The
Remnant core of the Soviet Union yeah
yeah it is Vladimir Putin was KGB yeah
right it'd be like if if we finally got
rid of the Third Reich seven 20 years
ago they'd be like yeah he used to be a
Nazi well duh that was the government of
the Third Reich and when we mentioned
the tactics of the Nazis we'd be like
that was Germany that the country that
still exists yeah it was the Nazis that
had usurped the German Throne miles if I
could just ask you really quickly from
your experiences on the ground there
were people worried about this
escalating were people worried about
nuclear explosions and tactical nukes
when you were there what was the what
was the gist of what people were seeing
there and what they were thinking was
going to happen there so I was speaking
mainly to the women and children at
first and a lot of them don't have a
hope in War because they know their
governments like Ukraine is very corrupt
in general and I'm pro-ukraine but you
know they have a lot of issues so they
don't think that Ukraine's gonna be uh
acting in their best interests in
general and they talked about the idea
of a nuclear weapon going off because
they know if a nuclear weapon goes off
um that the Ukrainian uh government will
get tons of funding and support and
everything like they're doing now so
it'll probably let it happen or even
escalate it to that point on purpose
that's all some of their theories and
some are soldiers are speaking to my
front lines of card keeper saying yeah
we we're seeing this right now we're
actually winning we can see them being
squeezed basically and when they get
squeezed they go panic and something
will be set off but they also told me
how the nuclear weapon system works in
in Russia so in the US you know Joe
Biden he has a Joe Biden moment maybe
presses a butter driver he has a nuclear
football exactly but in in Russia how he
works is the president's calls up uh you
know nuclear submarine goes uh ring ring
hello uh nuke please and then all those
people have to agree on it so there's a
two-step verification three-step
verification system actually yeah it's I
think it's like someone in the general
assembly and then they have to so it's a
number of people that do have to agree
that they're going to be launching the
nuke and this could be why allegedly
we're hearing reports again I'm very
skeptical whenever we hear you know
Putin was sabotaged here and here
because again you can't trust a lot of
these reports there's no evidence behind
them but it's three phone calls that
need to be made and three uh different
groups of people that have to decide yes
we're launching this nuke exactly yeah
unlike the United States where Biden
just brings in the nuclear football
launch exactly yeah and you gotta think
of a psychology of these people so these
ordinary people working for military in
a nuclear memory not earning so much you
gotta think okay well they were in the
Soviet Union obviously because they've
climbed so high since then and those
were the Glory Days where things were a
lot better than they are now right
um and they had that national pride they
thought they were top of the world they
were a superpower at that point and now
they're probably demoralized and they're
thinking well you know is it really
worth launching a nuke do I really
believe in my leader is our country
still great right now it's like
America's problem as well so I honestly
think it might just stop they might
order a nuke event they say hell no I
don't want uh my women
um back home my mother my wife my sister
to get nuked by the opposite country
because you know nuclear change I think
one thing we we uh we didn't consider
about nuclear war is that by the time we
would ever reach this kind of this level
of Crisis our cultures would have
decayed to the point where no one cares
enough about each other for this to
matter so you know even in Russia
they're experiencing cultural Decay
across Europe it's cultural decay in the
United States it's cultural decay
I'd imagine you know in the 50s people
were much more like America like as a
nation much more unified not anymore I
mean America's Americans are at each
other's throats and it's not even just
the left and the right there's some
factions of leftists fighting Democrats
and Libertarians arguing with
conservatives into varying degrees it's
serious
I can't imagine that someone's gonna be
like I have to do this to save my people
they're going to be like what people I
want to be rich you know a lot of people
have been dehumanized and I think that's
another aspect that we should understand
here when it comes to this kind of proxy
war that has people killing each other
in the fields uh there's a great movie
that just came out on Netflix uh what
was it called everyone's talking about
it right now the world war one movie
World War One movie uh absolutely great
movie and it shows you the the shocking
horror of realities and how these
politicians and these bureaucrats and
their High towers that are literally
deciding you know what
just go kill each other just go murder
each other and that is just and the
movie critiqued that very heavily uh All
Quiet on the Eastern Front All Quiet on
the Western Front definitely worth the
watch to understand here because the
same footage that I saw in that movie
it's the same footage that I'm seeing
when I'm trying to do my research on
what's happening in Ukraine and watching
the footage from the Russians and the
ukrainians it's almost identical when it
comes to because of the bombing the
trench warfare the the hand-to-hand
combat that you sometimes see the the
blood the explosions it's it's it's
something that is absolutely
uncomfortable unnatural for Humanity to
deal with this is why a lot of people
have PTSD this is why the the human body
isn't you know destined is is it okay
with killing another human being but for
some reason when someone puts on a
special costume in a uniform and tells
someone else to do it they do it that is
a stupid asinine idea that is
dehumanizing that is absolutely stupid
and backwards it needs to be challenged
more than ever right now well but I mean
you know there's too many people gotta
Bloom up right that's what Bill Gates
would said
you mentioned earlier that we're in a
state of cultural Decay I'm starting to
think it's not that but more that we're
in a state of cultural shock like the
globe has has we're basically all these
cultures have come face to face with
each other now we have communism in the
United States we've got uh American
republicanism in in in Iran we have
people doing like the the Arab Spring
people are like hell no I want to be a
republic and so we've got like it's this
like it is demoralizing shock in a lot
of ways but it's just it's just like uh
like the paddles have just shocked the
uh it's a new organism cultural organism
uh it can be a little it can it can be a
little harsh but uh but it's like
thinking that way has it so I'm not so
upset about the communism in American
schools and in American politics like
it's a natural part of the cultures
coming face to face this is just part of
it and it's up to us to stay positive to
have morale high so that our culture
comes out on top let's let's get to the
good news I guess you know we're all
concerned about nuclear war you know
Lord miles you mentioned that Joe Biden
has his finger on the button oh yeah
nuclear bombs well we got this op-ed
from The Washington Post for the good of
the country Biden and Harris should bow
out of the 2024 election from George
will this story went viral uh today this
guy voted for Joe Biden he hates Trump
votes for Joe Biden and now he's like
what did he say that Joe Biden has
displayed unwittingness or what is he
what does he call it I don't care to
read the whole thing the fact is
everyone's basically saying oh here we
go this is great he says meeting
recently with some Progressive activists
Biden said his 426 billion dollar
student loan forgiveness was
accomplished by a law that he had just
signed I got it passed by a vote or two
no he did not I love this because it's
two things the first thing is it's a guy
who voted for Biden being like no no
more Biden the second thing is well I
mean actually it's it's calling for
Biden to bow out and it's a guy
regretting having voted for him in the
first place so I you love to see it this
is what you get when you vote for a man
who is insane unwell is out of it and
now he's going on TV and just lying and
making things up and that's that's it's
absolutely Fascinating People still buy
it it's absolutely fascinating that
people will still vote for someone like
John fetterman Joe Biden claimed his son
died in Iraq twice now he claimed he got
a bill passed he didn't get passed and
people believe it they call Trump a
fascist but you want to talk about
fascism that's the fascism right there
that's the scary thing they sneak it in
with some bumbling old daughter who
makes random things up people buy it
they they March in lockstep behind it
but I'm glad to see that these never
trumpers are regretting their actions
and now calling for a substantial change
I guess the question is if not Biden
2024 not Harris who could it possibly be
I think it's honestly go be someone who
is just like Biden at the end of the day
they go make new promises say they go be
something different it's gonna be the
same thing repeating Stacy Abrams no no
that's Michelle Obama and Oprah both of
them running on the same ticket why
wouldn't it happen tell me make an
argument I think that's who else is
there Gavin Newsom yeah but the serial
killer looking dude and then that crazy
woman a witch which more uh which more I
said that by accident now I just kind of
realized
so seriously the The Butcher of the
nursing home uh people seriously who
else is there Pete budigen he's I mean
those are the only other two has
connections to intelligence so he's
going to be propped up in there in the
administration now he's the uh Megan
McCain no she doesn't have enough star
power at the moment who else well you
got nobody Hillary you're gonna bring
you're going to dust Hillary off I don't
think she wants bring her forward like
seriously I've been thinking about
Hillary a lot lately
because she's one of those you know they
say facts over feelings a lot of people
feelings Hillary's like the ultimate
feelings over facts person I feel like I
just realized this that if she likes you
she wants to work with you if she gets a
gut feeling like yeah yeah like she
could be she could be swayed to do you
see what you just said huh that people
are going to vote Republican because
they're too stupid to know what's good
for him she senses the emotions now I'm
paraphrasing what she really said is
that low information Americans don't
realize what a red wave actually means
for them but you know she's basically
saying y'all are too stupid to know
what's good for you so Lindbergh said
the same thing not Hillary not Bloomberg
I don't know who do you guys do you guys
see even hey she's too young she'll be
old enough but Michelle Obama Oprah I'm
telling you Obama Oprah the Oprah
Kanye you're telling me they would lose
I don't think they would lose no no I
don't know I would I would have said
that maybe four years ago but times they
are a change in men and I'll tell you
why
you take a look at some of the cultural
Productions and they have no impact The
Daily Show getting only a few hundred
thousand views like people believe in
different things maybe maybe
seven eight years ago you'd be like
Oprah's so popular people would vote for
today people are less concerned about
pop culture politics has become pop
culture so they're not going to vote for
someone like Oprah I mean she'd get
votes don't get me wrong she'd get a lot
Michelle Obama yes former first lady
absolutely maybe it's going to be Obama
Clinton or Clinton Obama
which Clinton
Chelsea Chelsea no politics Chelsea it's
going to be it'll be like a tech a tech
billionaire
could do it oh musk no he's not American
he's he's not he can never run for
president he's an African-American uh
Jeff's not gonna do it I don't know I
mean always on the Washington Post
that's writing we need a billionaire
president to fix things Amazon is the
greatest company ever Jeff Bezos soars
in the polls and then you you know you
understand why you bought it the rock
comically evil yeah yeah I mean he's
playing a little bit into politics he
supported Gavin Newsom he did a whole
political advertisement for him so and
he's he'll say anything for a buck I
mean look at the kind of movie he's in I
think well he's not as bad as that that
other dude who did that Chinese ad yeah
what's his name John Cena John Cena when
I say that's Pete butterjudge and you
guys like no no stop is it because you
really are afraid that he might win no
come on because it's like saying Mickey
Mouse you don't think has a chance no oh
I thought he doesn't have a personality
he doesn't have anything he like
remember when he disappeared for like a
month or something and no one knew he
was gone and it was like a major crisis
is with Trucking and Fuel and they're
like don't we have a guy for this and he
was just gone like nobody knew nobody
cared so I definitely don't see that guy
but also would you want to be a
politician in a falling Empire
everyone's gonna blame you for for all
the horrible things that all the other
politicians have kind of built up what
if what if this isn't the fall of the
Roman Empire this is the fall of the
Roman Republic what if Trump crosses the
Rubicon and we become a country that the
Republicans just keep winning because
the Democrats are psychotic and you end
up with a lopsided country that's like
55 Republican or at the very least
Independence voting Republican because
we've been traumatized by psychotic
Democrats sterilizing kids and and
things like that shutting down gas and
then you end up with a long period of
just consistent Republican majorities
maybe but the difference is that it's
like a global
um immersion now whereas the Romans were
still pretty insulated when the Republic
fell now we've got like every country on
earth is attempting to create a new
government in the United States and it's
kind of up to us to hold the wheel while
the storm rages outside who do you think
Miles who would have your vote I'm
actually hope I'm hoping no one because
then the Democratic party collapse and
then via Republican uh system we could
just take over the entire thing in Happy
Days for a while I mean look the
Republicans are bad for a lot of reasons
but we're seeing the split where you
have establishment Republicans and you
have Maga Republicans if the Republicans
win in a sweeping Victory then they win
in 2024 and the Democrats become
diminished you may actually see the
dominant party become Republicans and
this is a very very wild hypothetical
if the Democrats can't get a consistent
majority of Republicans eventually
they'll start jumping ship to try and
influence the Republican party which
will then split and take over the
two-party system I'm not convinced
something like that could like will
happen but it's a possibility if one
political party
put it this way the Maga Republicans are
very different from the establishment
but people are willing to vote for any
Republican at this point because the
Democrats are insane they're campaigning
on abortion as CR while crime is
skyrocketing in major cities in New York
there was like 30 people have been
pushed in front of trains like that's
freaking people out so Republicans are
like okay we'll stop crime and now you
get widely different views you get post
liberals people like me voting
Republican even though I disagree with a
lot of policies the Democrats are just
too nuts if that keeps up for a little
while eventually then you're going to
see the Maga Republicans and the neocon
types and establishment types split and
that will become the actual two parties
right there
crazy right or Civil War
well I don't know about that I mean
Civil War if the far left loses it and
refuses to accept the result of the
election look Joe Biden spoke today
about the the danger of election denials
or whatever deny deniers and I think
it's funny because the message is is
deeply needed right now because when the
Republicans win next week and it's
tremendous and insane they're gonna need
to come out and be like remember what
Biden said don't deny the elections but
you know they're going to do it gosh I
think that people should be allowed uh
and all maybe not encouraged to deny
elections but you should certainly be
allowed to posit that there are issues
in your elections especially with
evidence coming out of computer programs
hacking and flipping vote tallies but
but you can only do that if you come
from a certain political party if you're
from a different political party you're
going to be censored you're going to be
banned you're going to be punished
you're going to be ostracized by
Mainline society and called Dangerous by
Homeland Security but if you're Stacy
Abrams you could do it all the time did
you see it doesn't matter in Brazil
there's like giant crowds tens of
thousands of people demanding the
military come out and say this election
there's a huge protest today too it's
crazy they went to like the military HQ
that's scary man it's scary when you're
when when you're when your country
tribalizes that degree it it you know
what man I think
you look at someone like Trump or
bolsonaro I think they know what happens
if you really move forward with a move
like that
it's not going to be fun people are not
going to live good lives like you you
will have massive suffering it could
start a Civil War and anybody who's
actually seen conflicts knows exactly
why you do not want something like that
yeah I was thinking about the crowds in
Brazil saying that we think that
bolsonaro was illegally uh voted out we
think the election was fraudulent and we
want the military to do what if they're
wrong like what have they done what they
have tens hundreds they don't care about
getting the military involved like
right what they don't care they don't
care for a lot of people it's about the
truth but they're being it's being used
right now I will say you've got a lot of
people in the United States
agreeing with the protesters
I've not seen anything out of Brazil so
I I'm not going to say I know for sure
what's going on but I'll tell you
it's it's feelings over fact the facts
don't matter the feelings do and these
people are thinking one thing if
bolsonaro is not the president Brazil
suffers so it doesn't matter what
happened it matters that they do
whatever they can to make sure he stays
president yeah they block the highways
and asked the military to take over the
government that's that's serious come on
did you ever see any kind of civil
conflict I mean the the closest thing I
that I saw when it comes to something
like a Civil War was was what I saw in
Mogadishu Somalia different tribes and
different factions of people fighting
each other uh you know roadside bombs
and just shelling and fighting all you
know but but have you seen anything like
that oh yeah even in Brazil I've seen
leaked videos
um showing that the cartel was
celebrating that the guy got elected
because he's gonna protect him and you
think with how corrupt certain parts of
Brazil you know something was uh messed
with I honestly think at the end of the
day but I've seen stuff in South Sudan
as well so it doesn't matter who you
belong to in the country it just belongs
about the tribe so it doesn't matter to
be South sunnis South Sudan doesn't
really exist it's just about the tribal
people and the borders don't make it
yeah what happened yes so well real
quick like Brazil is let's just say
there's a lot of things about Brazil I
was down there and I saw the
pacification or the REM the aftermath of
the pacification the government went in
these were brutal videos they just
basically took over favelas the
government was so broken that for a long
time gangs in favelas were de facto
governments now they're trying to gain
control over all these territories I
don't think you're going to see
confidence in any of these systems but I
want to stress we're not Brazilian I
don't know what's going on in Brazil
other than we're watching news reports
about it and people are demanding the
military takeover so yeah I want
evidence if any I'm not going to make
claims without evidence that's for sure
but it's not it's not even that I mean
we're not Brazilian I don't even know
what like if someone came to you right
now and said like Miguel you know Perez
came out and showed this document like
dude I have no idea what you're talking
about I don't even know who that is the
issue is so if if something really bad
happens in Brazil there'll be another
immigration issue where they will go at
the Darian Gap all the way and cross the
border like what happened with Venezuela
too when the country fell though
Brazil's massive yeah I think I think
they can make it happen
um they got dollar coconuts in Rio I
don't want to be too bad yeah but at the
same time these people see American
thing oh better life there's no election
corruption over here I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna tell you this I I take anybody
who goes to the military and request
they take over I'm not trusting to be
completely honest like that's the last
thing anyone would want if you if you
think you legitimately won you then go
to the military and ask them to take
over your country it doesn't sound yeah
that's what some of the protesters are
no for sure yeah I I don't think
bolsonaro is doing I think he officially
conceded today he didn't concede okay I
think so I think I saw something right
before this broadcast with him
announcing that he's officially letting
uh I know I know that he was basically
he was beginning the transition but I
heard that he didn't concede what do you
see uh I read a post on Reddit sing
specifically that he did concede yeah
but again it's Reddit could be wrong we
don't know what's going on yesterday he
had not conceded yeah you might be right
but the transition was beginning like he
was letting go with power and following
the Constitution that's that's what it
was reported
I certainly hope you don't see a
military takeover man that's not fun
stuff no no but uh anyway Sudan
yeah South Sudan's uh world's newest
country and definitely shows at the end
of the day uh bribery is right if you go
around anywhere you have to pay money
especially if you're a foreigner like
myself you stand out like a sore thumb
for you and bears keeping the entire
country on uh Lifeline so they're just
handing out free foods and everything
but not actually uh funding any
Agriculture and bringing some uh farming
techniques to teach them how to be
self-sufficient it's just a money scene
for money laundering for Rich uh people
get richer because the uh the money
given by the UN our governments as well
is going to their pocket instead of the
average person living in a mud hut who
doesn't have enough food to eat today it
sucks and I think that could happen in
Brazil the end of the day you can get a
more tribal people fight
um amongst themselves like you said to
him you've got uh you've got people that
are belonging to certain areas not
actually the governments and Country as
a whole and they'll associate with their
tribal groups and then just fight
amongst themselves and I I think Brazil
could fall into that they could even get
to a point where so in part in Brazil
separate because the geography of a
country is so insane that I would make
sense at the end of the day and
bolsonaro just I'm just I'm just looking
at it right now he uh is urging his
supporters to stop the roadblocks and he
has authorized the transition didn't
concede yet so the Reddit post Rose
wrong let's talk about Newsweek
Joe Biden White House brags about social
security check increase caused by
inflation
this is one of the most epic mistakes
ever made by a political organization a
political Administration
they said
uh where's where's the Tweet seniors are
getting the biggest increase in their
Social Security checks in 10 years
through President Biden's leadership
what happened was Twitter had a
community fact check which said actually
it was a 1972 law passed by Nixon and
the reason the increase is happening is
because inflation is insanely High
so the White House deleted the Tweet
they accidentally celebrated that under
that inflation was caused by Joe Biden
you get that they said through Biden's
leadership
they're seeing this increase
talk about a major
cell phone
yeah that and I don't like okay if my
dollar deflates so now it's worth 50
cents and I give you two dollars
uh yeah okay you could say that the
value of the dollar goes down the money
is inflated so the value deflates we'll
call it that uh so if I give you two of
those dollars that are each worth half I
can't say that I increased the amount of
money I'm giving you yeah you can that's
what they do it's a lie I know this is
what America does the United States will
borrow let's hear a simple version they
borrow 100 bucks from Japan and that
hundred bucks is worth say 100 apples
like what's the real value
100 apples then they print another
hundred dollars cutting the value of the
dollar in half now that same hundred
dollars Japan has can only buy 50 apples
so when they when they say I gotta pay
you back they pay them back half it's
it's amazing how this stuff works yeah
yeah the value of the dollar has been
going down dramatically and and the
crazy thing is it's not as bad as it is
other places in the world like in Europe
and the developing world holy cow are
they dealing with larger inflation
numbers here we're still seeing
artificial way artificial ways that it's
being kind of tamed but there's a reason
why I have this Banker t-shirt there's a
reason their practices that they're
doing is absolutely immoral and evil and
at the end of the day just screws people
over because if you have a if you have
money say you're trying to save up for a
rainy day you put it underneath your
couch or your mattress whatever it may
be that value of that money is being
slowly liquidated Away by governments
unknown tax which is inflation and we
still haven't seen the larger
ramifications from it this is just the
beginning of the larger Financial
ramification patients that we're we're
seeing not just from covid but also from
those two thousand dollar checks that
everyone got it's it's it's crazy that
we have pretty much free money free
money yeah it's free it just comes out
of nowhere it's not free AOC what did
she advocate for debt spend deficit
spending yeah don't you know modern
monetary policy just print the money
spend it and devalue the savings of
everyone else yeah who cares yeah yeah
your wages become worthless and modern
currency is based on trust that's the
thing too and with the trust in the
government's going down dramatically
um and every other governments as is
with the recession going on too and
China becoming more powerful I I
seriously think the US dollar just can't
keep doing this taking every bashing
because it won't come out on top and at
the end of the day the world Global
Currency will switch on to something
else that's why China's devalue event
currency they're probably playing for
long game and one day they're gonna
bounce up and everyone will switch I
mean credits due where's due Russia put
their currency back up partially on the
gold standard rate do you say a price
shoot up but nowadays you know for
currency actually has no real value and
it's just uh it's just a paper straw
that's about to break basically yeah
China also is dealing with a lot of very
heavy Financial ramifications especially
in their uh real estate market and
there's just there's just so much
irresponsible centralized banking going
on that it's absolutely Reckless to have
any faith in the system if you have
faith in the system you might as well
believe in Clan in Santa Claus and and
uh the Easter Bunny you have more faith
and and those made up ideas than you
should in the banking system when you
truly find out what's really happening
behind the scenes and now we're on an
infinite Reserve System meaning the
banks can just print out debt endlessly
so expect inflation to get substantially
worse and never stop getting worse what
knowing that and having no or losing
faith in that system the faith-based
system the Fiat system actually means
Faith uh what would you advise I'm not a
financial advisor I'm buying Dogecoin
buys anyone I didn't say that I said
Dogecoin Dogecoin and uh no I'm kidding
I did buy Dogecoin but I I would not get
anyone advice on what to do because
honestly I have no idea I would say be
care I'm not a financial advisor but
what happened during the Great
Depression was a lot of people were
taking out loans on um margin margin
meaning they didn't have the money to
cover the loan if the value dropped of
the commodity that they were and then
the banks called the loans back in and
they had no money because the value
dropped and then they would have to sell
off all their assets at a loss to pay
back the Margin Call uh so I avoid I
avoid that right now I don't know what
the market could drop by at times you
know one thousand it'd become worth a
thousand I mean the problem is being
compounded because they've been
prolonging uh uh a correction they've
been making sure that there's going to
be no downturns in the economy and they
artificially do that they have been
inflating this bubble more and more and
more and because of that when it does
finally correct itself there's going to
be so much pain there's going to be so
much suffering and these policies were
just being deliberately done and we're
screaming hey this is stupid this is
stupid this is stupid this is going to
lead to more pain more Havoc more
suffering for everyone on and no one's
listening and we're just continuing on
with these same policies to now the
point where the correction is going to
happen it's going to be massive and it's
going to hurt everybody I saw a story
about this guy he found a a tin full of
cash in like his attic or whatever I was
like Grandpa hit up there and it was
something like 50 Grand or whatever and
they were like wow so amazing we found
50 Grand I'm like that sure does suck
yeah because it was worth 500 Grand when
your grandpa put up there if only bought
gold and put it up there or or stock and
empty lot in the city that's now all
around yeah we're like yup the cash is
worthless you'd think that like a
president's gonna come in and be like
all right everybody things are going to
be very very very painful here's why now
it gets painful that everyone would
blame that person that President like
you were saying earlier who wants to be
a politician in this climate like and
then what would they be looked at as the
worst president of all time because they
were the ones that finally allowed the
facetious system for a lot of reasons
Biden already is but sure any but he
hasn't he hasn't done the financial
break he's trying to like push it push
it push it kick it on to the next guy by
printing more money and like slowing but
it's just like CR building pressure so
that when it does explode it's going to
be a bigger explosion yeah maybe we
could transition to a better system
without having a giant explosion you're
still gonna have to pay the bills
right
I don't think you have to pay the
Federal Reserve back all that interest I
mean it's a private company what what
right does a private company have to
demand of the US government anything you
know I'm gonna be very cynical here and
say they're doing this on purpose
because think about it all these people
especially the body Administration by
thinking four-year terms nothing else
they don't think about 10 years down
live 20 years and the budget
Administration knows they've screwed up
with Biden completely they know they're
going to lose the next election election
I think they have some self-awareness I
honestly think they're just trying to
print as much money as they can line the
pocket of their friends like we're doing
right now until the next election cycle
in say two years and then the bag is
passed over to the new right-wing
president and then certainly um
everything collapses like you said yeah
it's gonna happen yeah it's their plan
they want to basically sync you know the
ship I have advice for people
buy chickens
chickens will live in pods they will eat
bugs and they will give you eggs I was
talking with our chicken tender Kim the
other day and apparently what you can do
is take cows in one Paddock they live
there they poop there then when they're
they've saturated the area you move them
to the next Paddock and then you move
the chickens into where the cows were
they start sifting through the cow poop
refreshing the grass they regenerate the
land we don't know the chickens destroy
the grass but they'll they'll actually
they tilled that whole it's crazy so we
so we we cut up we sectioned off this
area for the chickens and it was Tall
Grass the chickens went in and
annihilated it and get it ready for for
a crops they'll get rid of all the weeds
which is the grass and then they'll you
have right crop land but you mentioned
something that I want to add on
specifically here even the same thing
about chickens just to change the topic
on their favorite topic here uh I think
what you mentioned is right and it's not
just you know a politician that's going
to come and save us because if we look
at what's been happening here it's not a
democratic problem it's not a republican
problem it's a duopoly problem as of
course we got to remember Biden is
spending money like crazy he's
deliberately destroying the energy
sector he's he's passing the inflation
reduction act which doesn't reduce any
inflation at all and then of course we
had the other guy beforehand that also
spent a crap ton of money on the
military-industrial complex and started
handing that two thousand dollar checks
to everyone like it just came out of
nowhere so so whether it's Donald Trump
Biden or even Obama or even Bush or
Clinton before him they all made this
problem worse and what makes you think
that another Republican coming into
power is going to help this it's not
but you think that I think Miles you're
making the point that they're gonna plan
to get someone of the political party
they don't agree with in power before
they tank the economy and who's there I
think I think bigger than the economy as
soon as uh say the next Trump gets
elected basically now the Republicans
will win now yeah don't they'll win
they'll win the next election basically
but they'll cause the global crisis
they'll time it because they've got all
the numbers they'll go over calculations
I think they know what's gonna happen if
our time it's such a point that the big
recession happens when Republicans come
back into power and they'll go oh look
what Republicans have done they've come
into power it was bad under the bad
terms but that was because of trump and
then they'll say look they're in power
now it's worse than ever not even I
think Trump's going to be playing
playing the game here if it's a populist
if it's someone who's going to come and
be like hey I could finally represent
the people of America I think China Wall
Street and all these other larger
financial institutions and the Federal
Reserve will come to them be like you
will okay we'll we'll destroy this whole
game right now you better play along or
we're gonna tank the economy
deliberately and blame it all on you
what do you want there buddy and I think
the next president even if they're going
to be a populist even if they're going
to be representing the will of the
people that's the perfect opportunity
for them to finally drop all the bags oh
yeah you know I used to be an investment
banking analyst for a few months as well
and I've got still friends of our field
and I met Martin shkreli a few weeks ago
you know for a few meetups lovely guy
but they are sounding alarm Bells right
now they are basically saying hey I'm
gonna put some extra money aside and
liquidate and put some crypto or I'm
gonna buy some extra food or I might buy
some Farmland you know and learn a
little bit about farming or raise my
kids to learn how to uh so close back
together and these are Bankers earning
you know two hundred thousand dollars
three hundred thousand dollars a year at
the minimum things will only get worse
you will own nothing and you'll be happy
check out this so I'll give you one of
my shirts next time you're around them
you could wear them if my creator
doesn't pop off and I have to go back to
that lifestyle I'll wear that to the
interview let's check out this story
here
California governor Gavin Newsom admits
the Democrats have been destroyed on
messaging and crushed in the narrative
as they race a republican Red Wave in
the midterms and here's the RCP
projection there it is the updated map
shows Republicans taking 54 seats
Democrats 46 New Hampshire is going
Republican they're saying Arizona Nevada
Georgia New Hampshire
all going Republican
now I got a question if if zeldin in
some polls is leading in New York could
New York possibly go Republican in the
Senate as well that'd be huge you you
could could you imagine what would
happen if the Republicans actually took
over 60 Senate seats
that'd be crazy that's a lot of pod
people in New York City I'm gonna start
calling people that live in apartments
and in deep cities pod people it's kind
of it's kind of a term of endearment
guys I know you're listening right now
no it's not I lived in a pod for many
years so it's not it's not an insult
they're looking around the apartment
from wall to wall like uh five feet to
five feet is going yeah I guess cement
so as as everyone in here has always
been the staunchest of Republicans uh
how are you going to celebrate how are
you today how are you going to celebrate
when your favorite political party wins
Supreme control over the government in a
week you're just trying to trigger me
right now trigger you no one I I don't
like you're not even American Serge are
you Republican no then no one in this
room has has been a traditional
Republican no and here we are being like
no it's better they win I guess yeah
yeah I mean we can acknowledge the
Republican party is mostly trash but we
don't want the Democrats to win when it
comes to this I don't even know who the
Democrats are that are running so to be
honest I vote for people I don't vote
for political parties like the people
are better but they have a tattoo on
their shirt oh yeah I will not vote for
John I would not Advocate voting for
John fetterman because like he just
suffered a stroke he's not in a healthy
mind state right now I'm not a huge fan
of Dr Oz politically but he seemed
cogent he's more cogent than fetterman
at least you know yeah yeah if
Republicans today are just for Democrats
uh 10 years ago
literally yeah we should get a little
time there before they fully Implement
all the agenda when the uh who does who
does RCP Real Clear Politics how do they
get their numbers it's a it's a a an
aggregation of polls so you've got a
bunch of different polls that's what
they're basically yeah we also got to
understand the polls are routinely wrong
they were telling you that Hillary
Clinton had a 99 to 90 chance of winning
the election but they're they're wrong
by like seven points against the Dem
against the Republicans meaning if
they're using the polls to show a
projection of 54 Republican seats and
they're off again by 7 to 13 points that
was like the swing I mean it could be
way more I don't yeah look if the let's
say this so when we look at uh New York
Senate Schumer versus pinyin Schumer is
up 18 11 17 14 and 12. if the polls are
off by 13 points and that's that's
massive I really doubt it I really doubt
it then it could be a tie but I I don't
think so I do think however if people in
New York go out and vote they absolutely
could get a republican in the Senate New
York if every single person went out and
vote the polls are meaningless because
Democrats aren't enthusiastic right now
they're upset about Democratic
Leadership the gas prices are are too
dang high and so right now the
Republicans who are enthusiastic have
have an opportunity these polls show
Schumer way up sure but how many of
those people want to vote for him say or
who say they're in a vote for him
actually care to go out and vote the
Democrats aren't offering you anything
so they might not even show up
I I kind of worry about blue Texas at
the end of the day I mean ever since for
California started running away and then
saying oh wait California sucks where's
vote is actually the same in our new
state I think we could see some
surprises but uh Texas has been turning
redder yeah that's good that's good news
that's because a lot of conservatives
have been really no no no no vote in
South in this in in the Rio Grande
Valley flipped from Democrat to
Republican yes so I mean people are fed
up with the Border crisis yeah not only
people that are from like is that where
Elon Musk also voted he voted also for a
republican yeah he said anybody
Republican yeah Elon Musk good look at
this New Mexico is being projected as
going Democrat right for the for the
governorship but if the polls really are
busted swinging up to seven points then
it's it's actually leaning Republican
but I don't know I'm not a pollster I
don't know to what degree the polls will
or won't be busted this time around New
Mexico doesn't have any uh Senators up
Colorado the Bennett in Colorado against
O'Day is up uh two points in the latest
Paul from trafalgars eight from Emerson
six from Marist and nine from dfp
overall spread of 6.2 if the polls are
off by seven points Republican could win
there everyone needs to go out and vote
what does it show in Arizona with uh
Carey Lake uh with Kerry Lake oh I think
it's it's hands down I think the
projection it's showing it's contested
no it's up like across the board oh wow
yeah there's like one there's one one
poll showing a tie and one with hops up
one but let's look at
um
Senate in the Senate Arizona is leaning
see this is interesting all the polls
show Mark Kelly leading in Arizona yet
they're projecting Masters will win
why is that yeah well it'll be
interesting to see what happens man
be right one way because because they're
project because is it is it because
they're like hey look we think the polls
are going to be wrong New Hampshire I
think even shows for the most part
Hassan is up but Bolduc is up one in the
Saint and Anselm poll didn't Tulsi
campaign for uh Bolduc yeah she just
endorsed them I'm pretty sure right yeah
oh no no she just endorsed Masters
Tulsi gab amazing that she left Congress
and is more influential now maybe that's
why she did it might have been yeah she
couldn't have done anything in the part
in the party who knows she could have
left the Democratic party a while before
it is very true yeah Bernie too yeah
Duckworth man Illinois what is wrong
with these places I mean it's going to
be interesting to see what happens in
Arizona and Pennsylvania I mean that's
pretty much where I'm going to be
keeping a close eye on on Election Day
because that's going to decide the
future of this country oh yeah what's
the Pennsylvania polls look like right
now Doug mastron I think it's favoring
fetterman various parts yeah he's up
point four how I don't even know
decision desk said Oz's chance of
winning is 54 percent to like
fetterman's 45 after that debate I I you
maybe you should have to watch the
debate to vote I don't know but how do
you know how do you make sure this is
why I think service guarantees
citizenship right oh you don't even need
ID to vote trust me they're not going to
put any barriers to entry this this
right here I feel like with fetterman
and Oz it's like a test aliens are
putting us through and they're like
they're in the spaceship and it's like
beat by are they voting for fediment
they are ah like they're testing us to
see if we're worthy of joining the
Galactic Federation but we're voting for
a guy who's who's actually got brain
damage and can't speak or understand
words that just goes to show you that
these people are not serious people the
voters are not serious people they don't
care and if anything if there was a
conspiracy I'd argue it was an attempt
to make learned people wish for
despotism because you realize how many
stupid people there are that will vote
themselves to jump off a cliff that's
why we built the federal government to
begin with OR at least why we built the
Senate that's why we aren't a democracy
yeah Republic yeah we have better men in
quotes for now in the Senate to make
sure that the mob doesn't vote in more
honesty I don't know more honesty make
it up words it's okay to do that it's
totally fine all right so totally okay
we're gonna have a big show on Election
Day we're gonna be we're gonna have
pizzas and wings and we're just gonna
sit here I'm gonna eat like a bowl of
wings beef liver I'm gonna bring the
beef liver yeah change it up here a
little bit
I I gotta I gotta say look if you think
the Republicans won already then they're
gonna lose for real yeah you're not
gonna go out and vote and that's what
that's what they're hoping for the
reason we may be seeing these stories
like Republicans are going to win is
that Republicans like okay I don't gotta
go out no no no now is the time you got
to go out because I'll tell you this if
they're saying you're gonna win already
then make it a super majority make it
like a crushing defeat like people talk
about when you're when you're defending
yourself how you got to make sure you
stop the fight you know you have to make
sure you use adequate Force to prevent
someone from being able to fight
when we're talking about politics you
want to win a decisive political Victory
to the point where the Democrats feel so
demoralized they drop these garbage
ideas they have a Reckoning where they
say Hey you know those things we're
promoting that really hurt us in a way
we've not seen in decades let's not
advocate for those things anymore that's
what we need to see
send a message yeah and also don't
celebrate when your candidate wins you
got to hold their feet to the fire and
make sure they represent you properly
this it's just a tendency in American
politics for the once they get into
office to just fall into the oligarchy
pocket and it is up to you to run this
country we are running this country
together the people on Election Day are
we gonna are we going to start early or
is it just eight to ten minutes it's not
eight to ten we're probably gonna go
late there's not gonna be a members only
we're gonna just just chill here and
have pizza because like you might we
have people rotating in and out we might
be waiting a long time to see what
happens in Pennsylvania yeah it may go
on a few days yeah we may be trapped
here live for a few weeks let's do a
Telethon Telethon yeah no I think we
might go we can raise money for beat
blarp all right election night just let
the live stream roll we'll hang out
maybe like as we're chilling for results
play some music maybe we'll work the
commander next play some Magic together
that'd be awesome while we're waiting
get some coffee I like it I like those
days where people just roll in and out
kind of like take seats you get up and
leave come back yeah we're gonna have a
bunch of people here actually and we're
gonna have people chilling in the seats
and they're gonna come in and swap out
and it'll be fun it'll be an extended
show but uh you know we'll see we'll see
I don't know if we can make surge press
the buttons for that long well luckily
I've got some other people that are
learning how to do this too there we go
it's actually a great opportunity so
we'll be like the Buns may be pressed
incorrectly but we don't maybe I'll push
the buttons for a few minutes you don't
want to do it for days and days and days
sir come on what kind of what kind of
what kind of attitude is this
we gotta wait until the votes to in
Pennsylvania get in yeah take a look at
this how long you think it's gonna take
a couple days who wants to rate this one
Ian you guys yeah let me see it there's
a glare on the screen so uh I got this
Panic is starting to set in I
for Democrats it's just it's not just
Nevada and multiple key States Democrats
are not hitting the early vote Plus vbm
numbers they need to counteract an
election day Red Wave John rails from
election wizard John Ralston says for
those wondering I just confirmed that
there is no backlog of mail waiting to
be processed this is not a good scenario
at all for Dems unless USPS not
processing fast enough no massive Clark
mail is in 2020 as I have said this is
an apple other Cycles are oranges so
basically they're hoping there was a big
stack of mail-in ballots that are going
to get jammed up that would be good news
for Dems it ain't there so this might
actually end that night very decisively
you know American one of the things
Americans have always been great at in
my opinion is
being real like this country came from
hard times and when you see someone like
Joe Biden
just flubbing things it's you can't your
spirit cannot deny it it's it's too hard
to pretend like that's okay for a long
time
and that I gives me hope unfortunately
it's like you got to be demoralized to
the place where you give up on the
American dream but it was a nightmare to
begin with you know it was all the
American dream yeah it was all based on
conquest and like OPEC dollar forcing
people to use our dollars well that's
capitalizing off the back of the
destruction of Europe extreme something
very different it's basically that with
a single job you can buy a house get a
car race two kids some chicken yes no it
is that's the American Dreams one person
from nothing can come up and have a life
like
upward Mobility yeah and then what
happens is you get a bunch of these
communist college students who think it
means you can literally not work and
just be rich the American dream was that
you could move to America as a Chinese
immigrant move your family into a studio
apartment and then work eight eighty
hours a week until you finally put your
kids in college and then they then they
get jobs making fifty thousand dollars a
year and don't have to go through what
you did then they can have cell phones
in their own apartment that was the
American dream and then all of a sudden
these these communists come out and
they're like the American dream is dead
since when was the American dream that
you're born to an upper class family go
to college and then get a mid-range
six-figure job at a tech firm there's
these are people who get jobs at like
Vice and do literally no work all day
don't even show up at the time and
they're like the American dream is dead
there's a video did you see the viral
video of that of that tick tocker on
Twitter the Starbucks yeah yeah she uh
no I had to work eight hours on Saturday
it's like oh oh man it's a it's a a tick
tocker working at Starbucks crying
saying we need a union because they
schedule me to work eight hours on
Saturday and Sunday and it's wrong and
it's not fair the American dream was
that you got to work 16 hours a day and
you got to make enough money to
eventually put your kids in a better
situation that was the American yeah the
immigration story is the story of my
family you know my dad had to sacrifice
a lot risk a lot and fleeing the Soviet
Union yeah I mean working for
essentially slave labor uh off the books
to try to of course bring me over to to
the United States to give me opportunity
and I know there hey we I have a lot of
opportunities here that I wouldn't have
in Poland I got to take advantage of it
I got to make sure that I'm on my A-game
I gotta make sure I gotta work hard
because at the end of the day no one's
gonna give you anything and that's a
lesson that a lot of these people need
to learn immediately here's the American
dream that Luke's family were Poland was
a Soviet satellite it wasn't officially
Soviet Union is edit yeah so your family
flees is very this hardship to come to
America and
30 years later or 20 some odd years
later their son having having his father
having sacrificed all this his son
appears in a Times Square billboard ad
several a couple a couple times
that's the American dream well I don't I
don't know you know in all seriousness
do you think your dad ever expected that
the life he would give you would lead to
something so tremendous he he made sure
to make me aware of it when I was
growing up he was like I I almost died
coming here a number of times so you
better make something out of yourself
because if you don't no one else will no
one's going to give you anything here
you got to work hard for it and was he
like why are you chasing around these
people with a camera yeah yeah like he
was like go to college become a doctor
or a lawyer I'm like I hate all these
people and college is a scam and the
whole the whole economy is gonna gonna
fail and then this was right before 2008
I remember that car ride going to school
I was like I'll do it for them because
otherwise I wish I would have never gone
to school but I did it for them I got my
little piece of paper I gave it to them
as soon as I graduated I'm like here you
go this is pointless I wasted a lot of
money I wasted my time I made sure I
took no money from them I worked a
full-time job doing that but this is the
kind of ethic that they teach you you
got to work for it you can't take out
loans you can't borrow money that you
don't have you have to earn it you have
to work for it and and that's something
that I see a lot of people missing
people don't have that people don't have
that hunger or that P you know people
always said you know like hey they went
to journalism school and I remember
being there with them they're like yeah
we got to wait four years we're gonna go
through all the lessons and we're gonna
go out there and maybe interview some
politicians I said screw you I'm
stealing a press credential finding out
how you guys do it making it on my own
facing the mayor off next week and I did
and the mayor ended up calling the
school getting me in trouble but that's
a different story uh but but I went out
there I was hungry I hated these
politicians who were lying to the people
no journalist was asking them any
legitimate questions and I was like I
have to do it because no one else is
doing it this is my opportunity to
finally fill a void in society that
could help them and that's when I when
it went on my spree confronting all the
politicians all throughout the United
States there's two American Dreams in
the story your your mom and your dad
fleeing a hardship to give you a better
life and you coming from a family that
had to flee and then making a a better
life for yourself through hard work
that's the American Dream well it's
waiting right there for you it was
coined by James Trussell Adams in 1931
American dream and his quote life should
be better and richer and Fuller for
everyone with opportunity for each
according to Ability or achievement I
agree with the sentiment the reality is
the Federal Reserve is deciding who gets
the money and if you are born into
poverty you don't have any money so the
dream is like were you born into wealth
did you listen to a word we just said
yeah the upward Mobility like free
speech allows for people to create great
work but unless you play the game the
fascist game what game is Luke getting
federal or is there paying taxes he's
he's shorting the war in Iraq by paying
taxes oh come on it's not personal but
we've all been part of this there's
there's very few people in the world who
have done uh more combating the false
narratives of the war in Iraq than Loop
dude Luke is a golden god
duration there you know my point is
there's a lot of bad things we fight
against them but the reality is in the
United States which is very different
from many other countries on this planet
you can be dirt poor and work hard and
succeed and there's one there's one
factor they found this is scientifically
proven perseverance yeah well you can be
rich and fail and they they you read
these studies they're very fascinating
there was a TED Talk I watched where
they said they found they went to kids
who were born to multi-millionaire
families to billionaire families and
these kids were failing Hunter Biden
look at him how about that and they say
what was causing them to struggle and
fail so often now of course with Rich
families they're never homeless but the
dude's teeth right out of his face his
laptop is full of all this just just
destruction and Chaos total failure
it was there was one factor no matter
how rich you are no matter how smart you
are no matter how strong you are
perseverance was the one factor in
success and Miles I think you also take
Life by the balls as well you you've
taken advantage of some crazy situations
traveled everywhere what's some of the
craziest places what's the craziest
place you traveled to well Paul from the
Tim cast Studio I I I would honestly say
Main Place in Afghanistan and those
people there work very hard as well and
they've got the same issue they do it
it's America in America because in
America you know you uh you pay for an
expensive degree and you you can't get a
job afterwards basically even if it's
sometimes a good degree
in Afghanistan they actually get free
and very heavily subsidized degrees as
well so these people uh have pharmacy
jobs and they're actually just working
on the streets saying bananas so they
have the same issues I think at the end
of the day
um and that's why I think Afghanistan's
crazy they it's basically um a failed
U.S state because that's why it was for
20 years that's what we did he made it a
puppet state and then now he's seeing it
all crumble down you would need a
hundred years of social engineering to
actually succeed in with this nation
building stuff it's it's ridiculous
ridiculous concept this would be
controversial um if you really want a
nation build you you cannot have the
population survive because at the end of
the day these people are not gonna give
up their religion and their beliefs and
they're very solid and they're
completely different from Western
beliefs you see that in Europe as well
you see all these uh people coming
across illegally and they just don't
integrate they just don't get on and
with Afghanistan it just made them a bit
more radical yeah that's well this is
why you need 100 years you need to erase
previous generations you need to have
the kids who are growing up be brought
up in in a culture that is that is
westernized American and then when they
grow up you have to make you have to
keep separating their their the the the
younger Generations from the older
Generations so that a hundred years can
go by and they can completely have you
can have erased their culture and
traditions it's the only way you'd be
able to do it tough to do because
Afghanistan is Desert so you got like
the greatest things about the United
States that makes it us able to live
like this with huge cities is the
Imports of grain and and corn and stuff
like that Afghanistan is none of that
yeah Afghanistan's technically not even
a country at the end of the day before
vibration made it it was just an enclave
of uh several States surrounded by
mountains and dude have a village here
then they wouldn't contact the other
Village on the other side of the
mountain it was a bunch of tribes
infighting but when when they were
pressured by the Russian Empire and the
British Empire fake basically came
together and said oh one struggle and
fought every single person you know with
the American dream conversation like
there are there is room for upper
Mobility I agree with that but I think
this this what is this guy's name again
that created the the term anyway the guy
that created the term it's 1931 it
sounds like Federal Reserve propaganda
if you work hard you can make it they
just want a bunch of slave workers like
hard work doesn't get you anywhere if
you do it every day at McDonald's you
got to work smart that's true I disagree
with you you will be working for 14 an
hour until it's about learning service
you can learn by working at McDonald's
how customers work what people are
buying when they're buying it you could
meet like-minded individuals you could
make connections there you could learn
how businesses are run you could learn
customer management you could learn so
much about why McDonald's is successful
and you could take what you learned from
being inside of that company learning
their secrets and implementing in your
own business that's working it's not the
CEO of UPS like start as like a loader
of a truck or something I think so yeah
and there's a lot of those stories how
many people can do this though how many
people could be entrepreneurs how many
people could solve our own business or
do their own little Independence
scientifically all that matters is
perseverance as long as as you as you
you remain convicted to your goals you
success
there's there's like okay I'm I didn't I
I I I read tons of scientific studies
where they tracked Decades of people
unless you're smart just look it up
unless you're smart you will continue to
repeat the same problem that's keeping
you in the position a little bit of
smart but hungry perseverance and
wanting it really bad that's the key
right there that a lot of people are
missing and they give up because their
mental mind state is is that they're
going to be unsuccessful you've got to
be smart to succeed in the United States
you got to be hungry to come from no
money you have to make money that's not
true yeah how can you be hungry when you
you've got loads of fast food be given
to you when everything's been handed
someone a super plastic you're not
starving but at the same time you're
staying afloat and that's keeping people
complacent at the end of the day it's a
choice and that choice is go to
McDonald's go get some beef liver go get
some vegetables they're a lot cheaper
and and but but it's all about where you
decide to take your time and I think the
one thing that is standing in the way is
taxes regulations and rules and license
senses that do prevent a lot of people
from starting their own businesses from
being able to commence Commerce where in
the United States you have police
officers shutting down lemonade stands
if we should be doing one thing is
teaching people positive mindsets and at
the same time getting government out of
the way so people could fix our problems
financially through just pure real
capitalism we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
Channel and share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
we're gonna have a members only show
coming up for you at about 11 pm and
don't forget head over to losing my
mind.net pre-save the new song genocide
the videos coming out Friday morning
along with the song the song it's uh
it's overtly political we're putting out
right before the election for that
reason the music video is even better
even better the song is um it's
basically about institutions and uh
that's there's a reason why it's called
genocide I'm losing my mind it is a and
and you'll notice the image on losing my
mind.net is a news anchor desk with the
covid uh with with I'm sorry I didn't
say that a virus a virus an unknown
virus an unlabeled sickness what is it
called um what's that kind of it's a
specific kind of uh virus I don't know
covet's a specific type of virus what
kind of virus
yes yes
coronavirus is there a smiley face a
smiley face oh it's gorgeous all right
here we go Matthew reckamp says Sheamus
has made several parity political parity
political ads recently could you ask him
for me what it would take to get him to
buy ad space on YouTube for them
perhaps I don't know I don't know what
you're referring to though
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr in the
chatty says Tim haramf I say no amnesty
no compromise no mas we try to be
reasonable they have decided this this
for us fine now fire with fire is the
only way they're gonna wish they just
let us be let us just be I'm saying I
hope many of these Maga Republicans file
subpoenas launch investigations Joe
Biden gets impeached all of that stuff
we saw under Democrats
normies get out says Luke I'll buy all
your shirts if you say abolish the ATF
in your intro
well it's too late for that but uh
that's I should make an abolished ATF
shirt
um but yeah boss ATF obviously why
wouldn't he say that that's like any
common sense
I saw that one and I thought he meant
you have to abolish the actual agency
and then he would buy all the shirts but
well you don't have to buy all the
shirts but you know thank you for that
darkos says I didn't believe Ian was 43
and when I look him up I can't find his
current age anywhere except for a place
that said he was 31 and went by
crossmack ah yeah that's my first
YouTube channel is cross Mac and you can
see I was 26 when I started making
videos in 2006 27 something like that
born in 79 I don't know how to confirm
it though Ian's actually 23 23 years old
23 years old that's right it's very
young man very young
let's see what we got here
Toy News quarterly says if politics are
frustrating you I'm starting a magazine
focus on action figures and toy
photography find me on
IST on Instagram okay IST Grimm there
you go
I am says Eon is playing the slow game
and that's how the left always wins by
obstructing every move along the way he
needs a rapid action plan to win
right he goes in and says I can't act
rationally I'm going to talk to them and
then they just slowly erode and Claw
and then eventually uh he's just sitting
there along with the council being like
I understand why you want to ban Alex
Jones again yeah that makes sense we
can't let him back on the platform
there you go
there's a good uh good Elon impression
down
alahad says Tim how come you are
releasing the song the same day as Tom
McDonald too much awesomeness for me
thank you for recommending his music
much love from Mexico Time McDonalds
fantastic uh he's got a song coming out
so the reason people put music out on
Fridays is because that's when billboard
begins calculating the the metrics for
the song and the reason why Friday is
going to be a big song release day
especially if you do political music is
because the election is that Tuesday so
we really want this song to hit right
before the election we want it uh you
know people on Monday to be listening to
it the uh the video itself I think we've
uh it's it's probably gonna be
controversial it literally will be
controversial and probably generate a
bunch of I'll end up trending on Twitter
because of it and then uh Ian's got the
best part in it in my opinion yeah I'm
not going to say too much but uh the
video itself you know we're just pushing
some boundaries great surprise guests
that's all I thought so too a great
surprise guest technically not
technically not technically so
technically not metaphorically
um uh you know uh for uh what's what's
figuratively
figurative guests yes and um legally
distinct from guests appearances yes yes
there you go all right everyone you're
all hyped up losing my mind.net
okay
mizero says Tim can you shout out one
very important thought by Boards of
Canada I think everyone should hear it
well there you go is it a song or
something yeah it is gorgeous Canada oh
cool
all right
Samuel latcher says get ready for lots
of delayed election results due to
Extended vote counting Tim where are the
4 pm segments I never see them on
YouTube they're on YouTube
I don't know I see him yeah
they're they're there
Monday a Friday and Monday I did live
streams though so uh oh that might be it
yeah if you didn't see those two but uh
it's crazy I might YouTube is basically
screaming in my face to do live streams
instead of recorded segments because
they got like double the views of a
standard video by going live so it could
just be that there was really big news
sure but I think YouTube probably just
like live streams
probably
kcb says question for Ian if given the
choice between open source internet or
perfecting nanotube Nano onion
technology which are you picking
open sourcing it's not enough if you are
going to free the software code of large
social networks I'd choose that but it
needs to be agpl3 as a software license
because people are going to take them
and add things to it and we need the
additions to also be free
I go with that we can make the graphene
on our own
Chad says Tim it's Chad from Twitter
please return my wife's calls you stud
no she needs to leave me alone
I guess I don't know sure
all right Gabriel Martinez says Luke
Satan was unavailable it's called the
ADL
Revelations 2 9 yikes hmm
Caper 2x says the quarter Rings Jeremy
is Right turning Twitter around is like
steering a super tanker it's impossible
to do it on a dime let's give Elon time
to understand the mechanics of the place
before starting the radical changes yeah
but don't add fuel when it's going in
the wrong direction and that's exactly
what he did
Miss Mary says I hope everyone realizes
that Elon is up against a whole lot of
powerful people who could destroy the
entire platform at their whim he has to
work with what he has until he can build
what he wants
agreed agreed
Michael d'ambrosio hey Tim native Fred
neck here kinda odd having my hometown
always talked about of such a random
Place Libs and Democrats invaded out
west to flee what they created in
Baltimore and PG and DC that's right now
they're coming here they're coming to
West Virginia
yeah man it's funny because uh in in
West Virginia you know there's raccoons
there's Bears there's Critters and
people go out and we'll you know use
guns depending on the the Critter and
then uh that you can you can tell when
someone's from DC because they'll post
online complaining about like the
gunshots or whatever and then all the
natives are just like is this a joke
like I remember I went outside weren't
even in Maryland and it sounds like
automatic gunfire going off for like two
hours because there's just a ton of
people all shooting guns like crazy and
this is Maryland
you know but when you're in Western
Maryland you're basically West Virginia
these counties tried to secede they
issued letters like we want to join West
Virginia we don't like Maryland
I think that'd be great
what is this
oh I can't remember what your name is
but he says came across a Gizmodo
article today on Yahoo related to Julie
Powell's last tweet they say you
capitalize on premature deaths to push a
narrative basically sounds like slander
to me yeah she was the lady who uh she
died he's 49 and she had her last tweet
was that she had black hairy tongue
yeah dead cells on her tongue her
previous looks were also just very shy
scary stories and very bombastic yeah
stinky whistle teats says where's the
beef Elon Temple the beef we bought
those uh those epic protein bars oh I
just had one so they're so good yeah
amazing it's great it melts in my mouth
and it's it's yeah it's meat yeah which
one did you with the beef yeah the
jalapeno jalapeno beef so good so we got
protein bars
we wanted to get like the least amount
of ingredients possible and it's just
like
pepper garlic onions beef did you have
one mile no I need one yeah you offered
me one later yeah we got a bunch of them
we'll grab one so good real salty though
you don't need more than one no that's
all unless you're working out a lot
they're not that salty I had two and I
over salted but I wasn't I wasn't
sweating I don't think there's a lot of
salt they're really made for if you're
on the road or if you're working out
like that is really what those things
are for replenish your salt whoa look at
this Mike E says cut all the excess
carbs in my diet this time last year
after hearing Tim's success with it I
started at 395 last year and I weighed
in at 300 today
wow props man see that's what I'm
talking about get those sugars out of
there man good job man I mean I'm not a
doctor I'll just tell you what I did I
got rid of the sugar and I dropped 30
pounds and like I dropped 20 pounds in
like a month and then after that like a
couple months later the next 10 just
came off
so that's what it's all about get those
sugars out of there
and you know what I find too it's like
if you can go a few days without the
sugar you you get disgusted by it almost
yeah I you know so I I went we went uh
got like bubble tea or whatever and
those little balls are very they're
starchy tapioca balls yeah but like
they told me they don't put extra sugar
in it and when I gave it to me I took a
sip and it was it tasted like drinking
like actual Mrs butterworths he's like
imagine someone I'm just like I can't do
this man yeah the sugary drinks is where
they get you there's so much high
fructose corn syrup in there and if you
start cutting it down if you have a full
dose of it like I remember before a
couple years ago I just had you know
full doses of full drinks and I'm like
this is absolutely insane and you just
feel nasty when you when you drink it
also I've done the complete opposite
when coming to America I've eaten the
typical American diet of just fast food
every single day uh just because I want
to try it and I feel terrible man it's
so bad yeah when I go home I'm gonna
lose so much weight yeah Chick-fil-A is
worth it sometimes atypical American
diet that's what I want to start
referring to crap as oh yeah that is an
atypical lifestyle all right cjb says
Tim you neglect to consider Elon may be
using these organizations on the disinfo
board to run interference with media
advertisers in app stores it really
could be political chess and musk gets
final say on bands I have considered
that and my my point is with the opening
segment even after he brought these
people in they still attacked him even
after he said we are going to police
hate speech they're still quitting the
platform there is nothing you can do
they're psychotic and in a cult
so Elon can keep being like you know I'm
going to talk to them and play 4D chest
doesn't matter nothing he does is going
to appease a bunch of cultists
but I get it to be fair you know he's
trying sure let's see what happens let's
see what happens I still think we're
looking at a net positive with his
purchase but you know
what do we got
Keel says Elon needs to needs to say F
the money he could take any of his
private companies public and increase
his net worth overnight someone has to
say no to government yeah SpaceX it's
not public there's a lot of money
sitting right there yeah but you know
who's going for shares for leftists I
mean they go control it don't have a
majority yeah it's like it depends on
how many sells he's just we're not going
to Mars we're going to Uranus no your
anus
Juiced cyber new type says at this point
the best we can hope for is that Elon
runs Twitter to the ground and it ceases
to exist then a better alternative can
rise up
yeah I mean if tomorrow I woke up like I
said it's a picture of elon's face
winking being like Twitter's gone I'd be
like okay well I'm on Truth social I
guess
just go there
I mean I just don't really
care for Twitter it was already running
to the ground by the previous
administration
and I sat there and I talked with uh
Jack and Vijaya and
they're they're psychotic Jack Dorsey I
think is actually one of the worst
people say like you know he was a
figurehead he didn't really have any
power or authority
the dude had public persuasion he could
have said things and that would have
been enough but he didn't even do that
so spare me
I don't believe he was trying to do
anything man
okay where are we at
Jason Lippert says I think elon's goal
is to have Twitter follow the Overton
window rather than pushing the Overton
window
Maybe
Anthony Richardson says soon MTG as
house Speaker 2023 how do we make this
happen
convince a bunch of rhinos not to vote
for Kevin McCarthy
good luck
David Opera says if you want to haggle
with Elon over the price of Twitter blue
then four dollars and twenty cents is
your best bet I canceled my Twitter blue
today when I saw that Elon was
consorting with new knowledge and these
uh grievance organizations I was like
I signed up when they announced it
because they said that it gives you
access to all these different news
organizations who can read their stuff
and I was like okay so instead of giving
the Washington Post 10 bucks a month and
the Wall Street journalize other
organizations I can just give one fee to
Twitter and then read these articles it
never worked
it would be like free with fitter blue
and I'd click it and it just wouldn't
work
and then I just never got around to
getting rid of it then when I saw Elon
was like the you know I'm gonna charge
money and then go work with these
grievance organizations I was like I'm
out
you know I'm more than willing to pay
for Twitter at a moment's notice the
moment I see him restore these people
like you you put back on Project Veritas
I'll sign right back up how about that I
want to see some real actions to restore
those who are falsely removed and these
things gonna take a few weeks and it's
like okay well you know then in a few
weeks I'll sign back up for the time
being I ain't giving you any more money
yeah and it's if it's in a couple weeks
then they're not going to lose anything
how about that but I don't think anyone
should give Twitter money until Elon
unbans the political prisoners there's
absolutely no reason to do it not for a
blue check or anything else if he's not
going to actually stand up for free
speech don't give a garbage platform
free money
the left is mad because he's actually
gonna start he's argued that so they're
saying they're not going to pay him
because he wants free speech okay well
you know pick where you get your money
from
outer pz says Crowder got suspended from
YouTube for two weeks he hasn't been
given a reason yet now he won't be able
to live stream the election yo that's
legit insane dude I wonder if that's
from the video we were watching earlier
he had that doctor nope that was on
Rumble oh yeah he's been interviewing
now that he's on Rumble he can he can
say whatever but they didn't give him a
reason why they gave him a strike check
out Crowder on Rumble he's been seeing
some interesting stuff
yeah he deserves a reason you guys send
him something I think I think he needs
to sue Crowder you should file a lawsuit
immediately I'm not even kidding
um we saw what happened with Alex
Berenson file a lawsuit if they're not
giving you well I suppose the issue is
that they don't give you a reason that's
their actual legal defense it's when
they give you a reason you have you have
a standing to sue because now they're in
breach of contract if their reason is BS
yeah I don't think it's ethical to ban
anyone for any reason at any time it's
like they're trying to scare him by not
telling them what he exactly did so he
again is is just afraid to even talk
Doug blask says you're dropping on the
same day as Tom McDonald bold moved him
maybe not smart but bold actually it's
ridiculously smart why why would it be a
bad thing it's like it's not it's not
like a song it's a three-hour movie
we're both gonna put out songs that are
gonna be between three and four minutes
shout out to Tom McDonald we'll we'll
shout out his song and uh you can listen
to both of them yeah you can support
both artists like vote with your dollar
but we're also doing
um Big Marketing pushes and big
traditional stuff so actually I think
this song is going to do substantially
better than the first song we put out so
we put out only ever wanted it was at
the end of September
and this is like it's an apolitical song
so we know that we're going to get a
bunch of attention from the first song
we put out so we're gonna put it out it
did really well it charted on a bunch of
different charts across the board on
Billboard hit number two in in sales and
so uh all really really good now
everyone knows that we do music the next
one's got to be meaningful so we're
putting out a political song right
before the election and we're doing
traditional marketing with it so I think
it's going to do way better actually but
we'll see
Gerald Armstrong says Lord miles you
have competition now now since Tim is a
Scottish Lord
that's right yeah I showed him right
when he walked in that I'm a lord it's
very nice but my certificate's a little
bit fancier plus is it on your bank card
yet no can I do that oh yeah yeah you
walk into the bank you uh you pick the
busiest hour right because they won't
care you know they're not paid enough
and you go with a nice suit so you think
wow you're wearing a suit you can't be
wrong you know just like every banker
and then uh you just slide it across say
you bought some land in Scotland they
say wow so true and just put on your
credit file yeah yeah I don't know how
that works in the US though is that
you're talking about us or UK UK but I
think it's very similar plus it's worth
a try I mean think about it I just bring
in the little plaque it says
Proclamation you're the Lord you could
have mail start saying Lord pool that
arrives at the house
I've looked into it a little bit I
believe it's possible I own land thank
you my Lord I'll try not Milo you know I
I gotta be honest though I'm pretty sure
I can pull up my app for my credit card
right now and they let you put any name
you want in so this is City card
when they announced they're doing the
identity card or whatever it's called
where you can name yourself whatever you
want and they'll give you the card
people put in racial slurs and it worked
wow yeah I've got a few ideas back home
yikes man
Jason Van Cleave says you say virtue
signal but what we have seen from Elon
is an attempt to be as transparent as
possible
I get it I also think it's funny that
they dropped the price from 20 bucks a
month to eight because he haggled with
uh uh who was it
he was haggling with Stephen King on
Twitter and they dropped the price out
that's hilarious big ask he did the big
ask well somebody somebody commented
they said in case you were wondering if
Elon thought this through he's currently
haggling the price of Twitter blue with
Stephen King on Twitter and I'm like
that's actually really funny
he didn't plan this one out
all right
agamemnon's gym bag says Lord miles you
absolute Legend loved watching you and
Callum in Afghanistan where are you
heading next oh thank you well I can't
talk about where I'm going next because
the country might not let me in but on
the side there's an uh I'm totally
unrelated there's an island called Snake
Island in Brazil so if you guys want to
Google that and look into the uh look
into it I think you'll be pleasantly
surprised you were there with Callum so
those are two of you guys I didn't know
you were there with them I watched audio
Yeah I invite him to Afghanistan as a
joke and he actually went through a bit
and I thought well why not okay that was
powerful man that was good watching the
Taliban people the one spokesman from
Taliban they were like what do you think
of Joe Biden the guy's like we all love
Joe Biden because he left us all this
equipment that you see them driving yeah
exactly no when I went to the weapons
Market one of my YouTube videos I I
bought ex-us military gear and just
started shooting I went shooting with
taiban
um you know the armored vehicles the
Humvees uh in America they cost around a
million dollars to buy over there
fifteen thousand dollars wow I saw 50
pieces of night vision goggles uh they
retail here twenty twenty two thousand
dollars over there three hundred dollars
a piece if
Afghanistan the issue is the sanctions
me can't get them out I actually thought
oh I can I could take it through uh the
Horn of Africa then go through this way
and then I realized I'll be thrown in uh
you know a US black side for like 50
years
I wonder if there if they're like
yeah for those are just listening I'm
holding up my hand give it back get out
of here like like it's theirs I would
have been like my tax dollars paid for
this I'm getting it back at a lower cost
but that's I mean that's evidence that
the 300 20 000 night vision order to
surrender the equipment is now being
sold on the black market oh yeah to
China
and ah I mean if Joe Biden hit me up and
goes you know can you get some of that
stuff out I could get a few units out
guaranteed he has to pay me a little bit
yeah why would they not just buy it back
at that point yeah exactly but he's
beastly devil says Tim I told you to
watch Jordan clepper's segment on
visiting GOP rallies and spoke with Adam
kinzinger that claims if a Civil War was
to happen it would be the right Wingers
that would die no question
interesting I'll check that out I don't
think uh you know we've talked about
this quite a bit with the right things
they're going to win no matter what I
don't think that's necessarily true but
people understand what what exactly will
go down in this in the Civil War these
generals were West Point graduates they
were United States generals and military
men who then switched so you'd have no
idea what would happen there could be
some high ranking dude who goes well my
family you know is in California so
sorry guys I'm out and then you have no
idea who you'll be fighting
James Eaton says what's stopping Dems
going nuclear on the way out way out
they are
I mean like but what can they do you
know oh here's this one's interesting
David C Cronk senior says according to
the Brazilian Constitution the military
is the Arbiter of election issues huh
well there you go I guess
we'll see what happens man
chrome gear IRL says just saw a
commercial of Kellogg's Frosted Flakes
for dinner
oh
[Laughter]
that's the right response there yeah you
got you beat me to it Frosted Flakes
what is it sugar-coated starch wads well
wash your fevers to my children
yes Frosted Flakes for dinner isn't it
kind of weird that we pour milk over
cereal grains and then eat them yeah
animal fat and sugar do not go well
together
yeah one day I went downstairs and there
was a carton of half and half just on
the table and I was like what happened
what's going on wait what's happening
and then half and half is
um it's like milk liquids removed so
it's heavy it's a mix of cream uh what
how do you how do you describe it's half
and half because like half cream have
milk so it's a very heavy creamed milk
or whatever just serving basically it's
what just a dessert not really we use it
for coffee okay okay but uh you know
normally people put milk in their cereal
and then I came down and it was half and
half in a carton and then Sheamus walks
over and pours the half and half into
his bowl of cereal and I was just like
wow what are you doing that's a while
yeah I mean it's delicious for sure
apparently half and half in in uh no
wonder he's all cracked out all the time
what is it in some cafes in Brussels uh
half and half Dutch for half and half is
a mixture of white wine and champagne
okay depends on where you are I don't
use half and half I use heavy cream we
have excellent local Farm organic heavy
cream it is so amazing you put that in
your coffee that's what you're supposed
to do and did you whip it up no you'd
whip it up it gets really do put it in
put a little sugar on it and then whip
it up sugar get out of here or I did
coconut sugar you can do whatever but I
mean just a little you don't actually
don't need to and then you put it into
this thick wad of cream you guys don't
have FNAF no no we just have terrible
food in England okay so um sometimes
people just call it cream oh yeah a
coffee with cream and they'll bring out
a little thing of half and half and I
remember I was in London and I was at a
hotel and I was at I was ordering
breakfast and I said I'll have coffee
with cream and then went with cream and
then I was like yeah and she was like
um oh okay
and then she looked confused and walked
away and I was like huh and then she
came back with heavy whipping cream oh
oh yeah yeah okay and then I was like
that's awesome all right this was a long
time ago I I didn't normally put heavy
cream in my coffee now I do it regularly
every morning that's what I have I have
coffee Nitro cold brew with heavy
whipping cream and then it takes me like
five hours to drink that one cup because
I drink it slowly and then I have eggs
and bacon for breakfast so I whipped the
cream before I put the coffee in it's
cool if you have one of those uh
it's like a vibrating uh it has a
battery in it
froths it yeah so thick and sometimes
I'll put it in the blender with ice and
then it makes it like almost like a
milkshake yeah it's good super awesome
yeah
all right gamer Max says Schumer is
running in New York and up 12 right now
I think Washington and Colorado are more
likely wild cards
just go vote go vote if every single
Republican in New York voted it would be
a Republican state hands down but too
many people are like I can't win so I'm
not gonna do it don't get complacent
chat yeah you gotta go and vote just go
do it
just go do it all right let's uh let's
grab one more
Eddie F says Luke can you please make a
get hammered shirt
that's
a little bit over the target there uh
that's a little bit too spicy and I I
would feel bad making money off of
someone getting really severely hurt so
I would rather not do that but um
I I appreciate the idea all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share the
share with your friends head over to
losing my mind.net and you can pre-save
the new song genocide losing my mind and
you'll notice the graphic kind of
explains the video is going to be about
so it's going to be really great when we
drop this video on Friday and the song
comes out I think you guys will get a
kick out of kick out of it it's overtly
political and uh we're gonna have some
legally distinct from guests appearing
in the video that's going to be really
really fun
so head over to timcast.com become a
member one of a members only show coming
up for you in a little bit and uh follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me at timcast Lord miles you want to
shout anything out yeah just follow me
on Twitter to search Lord miles if
Twitter's still around in a few weeks
and go and follow I'm going on a good
Adventure so I think you guys might
enjoy right on could you tell me
privately your your next adventure not
now but but like after the show oh yeah
I'll tell you privately I've got some
ideas I think uh I think it'll be a
little concerned if you if you'll have
me I'll join maybe potentially you might
need life insurance man that's fine I
already dealt with that stuff my website
is uh Luke uncensored.com I did a really
interesting not safe for work video
today on that uh platform uh I'm doing
an AMA on there very soon as well and
I'm very happy I have it because again
what's happening with Twitter is
concerning but no matter what having
your own platform having your own system
having everything in your controls is
important and that's what I have and
that's what I'm building on
lucansert.com see you there well
everyone I will be seeing you later Ian
Crossland follow me at Ian crossland.net
pick up my book writing in the dark if
you don't have a copy yet you can get on
Amazon and other places where books are
sold and also I'll be streaming on
Twitch from day to day uh we'll figure
out the schedule as it goes follow me on
Twitter to find out when I go live like
I did earlier today miles your work is
really impressed you're really
impressive man it's really cool thank
you thank you and a lot of ballsy stuff
yeah I love it I love it I want to
remind you do not put your faith in
another human to get you by in this life
do not wait for a superhero to come and
save you it's not Elon it's not me it's
not Tim it's nobody it is you it might
be literally it might be luke I don't
know
hours no no no I think he's actually a
Jedi
it's not just a coincidence we're in a
simulation
uh take care of yourself do your best
and um build your own network
just just kidding but do it dude spin up
your own social network while we're at
it now we can Federate all right hey
guys I'll be in the comments tonight and
uh my name is serge.com see you guys
next time we will see all of you over at
timcast.com for the members only segment
thanks for hanging out cheers